I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hi, you guys. We are really excited about this week's episode. It's kind of special. It really is. We got to interview Mike Scherr. You guys know he played Moe's on the show. He was also one of our original writers. We got to interview him. And it was awesome. It was delicious. We loved it. We re-listened to it and were like, this needs
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。嗨，各位。我们对本周的节目感到非常兴奋。这集有点特别。确实如此。我们采访了迈克·舒尔。大家知道他在剧中饰演莫斯。他也是我们的原创编剧之一。我们采访了他。太棒了。太精彩了。我们爱死这集了。我们重新听了一遍，然后觉得，这必须
to be a whole episode. Yeah. We had just had so much to talk with him about. But first, we're still going to give you fast facts. Always fast facts, guys. You know. Always fast facts. Oh my gosh. And I feel like you're going to be like in your 80s and you're going to be like sitting in a corner mumbling like fast facts, fast facts, fast facts. And they'll be like, what's grandma talking about? Oh, she used to do this thing called fast facts. Well, these are Mike Scherr fast facts. Fast fact number one, Mike was on the writing staff from season one through season four. He wrote 10 episodes. And here's what they were. The Alliance, Office Olympics, Christmas party, Valentine's Day. That was one of our
做成一整集。是的。我们有太多关于他的话想聊。但首先，我们还是要为你带来快讯。永远都有快讯，各位。你们懂的。永远都有快讯。天哪。我觉得当你八十多岁的时候，你会坐在角落里嘟囔着“快讯，快讯，快讯”。然后大家会问，奶奶在说什么呢？哦，她以前做过一个叫“快讯”的节目。好吧，这些是迈克·舒尔快讯。快讯第一条，迈克从第一季到第四季都在编剧团队。他写了10集。以下是他写的那些剧集：联盟，办公室奥运会，圣诞派对，情人节。那是我们在重温时发现的
hidden gems in our re-listen. Branch closing, traveling salesman, the return, the negotiation, the job. That's the one where Jim comes in and asks Pam on a date at the end. I know. And Dunder Mifflin Infinity. You know, Mike told me the negotiation was his favorite Angela Martin episode. Oh, really? She's like getting titillated by hearing people recount the Jim and Roy like scuffle. Oh, yes. Yes. Yeah. He said that was his favorite episode to write for my character. I felt like he just liked writing for your character a lot. Your character always had great moments in his episodes. They did. I loved it when Mike was assigned an episode. Well, Mike also wrote the accountants webisodes with Paul Lieberstein. He played
遗珠之一。分公司关闭，旅行推销员，回归，谈判，工作。就是吉姆在结尾走进来约帕姆出去的那集。我懂。还有邓德·米弗林无限公司。你知道，迈克告诉我，《谈判》是他最喜欢的安吉拉·马丁单集。哦，真的吗？她听到别人复述吉姆和罗伊的冲突时，好像有点飘飘然。哦，是的。是的。是的。他说那是他为我的角色写的最喜欢的单集。我觉得他就是很喜欢为你写戏。你的角色在他的剧集里总是有很棒的时刻。确实如此。我很喜欢迈克被指派写剧集的时候。对了，迈克还和保罗·利伯斯坦一起写了《会计师》网络剧。他在剧中饰演
Mose in 13 episodes of the show starting in season two. He talks a lot about playing Mose in our interview. It's very fun. It is. His love-hate relationship with Mose. Well, here is fast fact number two. I'm going to talk to you about shows he's created. I think you guys know the show that he started on SNL. He was there for six seasons. During his time on SNL, he produced the Weekend Update. Oh, yeah. Yeah. From 2001. That's a big deal. That's prestigious position. Yes. He did it from 2001 to 2004. He, of course, was a writer on the office until 2008. He then went on to co-create Parks and Rec, Brooklyn Nine-Nine, and he created The Good Place and Rutherford Falls with our very own Ed Helms. Wow. Yeah.
莫斯，从第二季开始总共出演了13集。他在我们的采访中聊了很多关于扮演莫斯的事。非常有趣。确实如此。他对莫斯又爱又恨的关系。好了，这是快讯第二条。我要和你们聊聊他创作的节目。我想大家应该知道他在《周六夜现场》起步的节目。他在那里呆了六年。在《周六夜现场》期间，他制作了《周末更新》。哦，是的。是的。从2001年开始。这可是件大事。是个很有声望的职位。是的。他从2001年做到2004年。他当然也是《办公室》的编剧，一直到2008年。之后，他去联合创作了《公园与游憩》、《神烦警探》，并与我们亲爱的埃德·赫尔姆斯共同创作了《善地》和《路瑟福福尔斯》。哇。是的。
His resume is full of other shows that he's also produced on and written for. I have to give a shout out to one, Jenna, because I love this show. Did you know that he co-produced the comeback with Lisa Kudrow? He wrote two episodes, and I loved that show. I loved it. I found that out about him in the first season of The Office, and I was enamored with him. To me, that was superstar status that he wrote that just amazing satire. It makes me want to go back and re-watch it. I had forgotten that he worked on it, and when I was looking up his credits, I was like, oh, I want to re-watch the comeback. Well, fast fact number three, Mike Scher wrote a book. It's called How to Be Perfect, The
他的简历上还充满了其他他担任过制片人和编剧的节目。我必须大喊致敬一个节目，珍娜，因为我太喜欢这个节目了。你知道他跟丽莎·库卓联合制作了《喜祺》吗？他写了两集，我太喜欢那个节目了。我爱死它了。我在《办公室》第一季的时候就知道了这件事，当时我就被他迷住了。对我来说，他写了那种令人惊叹的讽刺作品，简直就是巨星级别的成就。这让我想回去重温它。我差点忘了他也参与过，当我查阅他的履历时，我想，哦，我想重温《喜祺》。好吧，快讯第三条，迈克·舒尔写了一本书。书名叫《如何完美：每个道德问题的正确答案》。他在一封电子邮件中是这样向我们描述这本书的：他说，
Correct Answer to Every Moral Question. Here is how he described it to us in an email. He said, it's a book about how hard it is to be a good person and how we can use ethics and moral philosophy to try not to screw up all the time, but in a funny way, not like in a homework way. The basic idea was to explain all the stuff I learned for the good place without giving everyone a headache. You guys, when we did this interview with Mike, our copies of his book had not arrived yet, but we have them now, and this is a truly special book. I started reading it, and I can't stop. I'm like binging a book. Same. I love it. I couldn't put it down. I was reading it last night. This morning,
这是一本关于当一个好人有多难的书，以及我们如何利用伦理学和道德哲学来尽量不总是搞砸，但它是以一种有趣的方式，而不是像做家庭作业那样。基本理念就是解释我在《善地》中学到的所有东西，而不会让每个人都头疼。各位，当我们对迈克进行这次采访时，我们的书还没到货，但我们现在有了，这真是一本特别的书。我开始读它，就停不下来了。我简直像在疯狂刷剧一样在读书。我也是。我太喜欢了。我爱不释手。我昨晚还在读。今天早上，
I was like, I want to read more. Like, I woke up thinking about it. Do you know what I mean? So, Mike is such an amazing writer. We already know that, but he takes this conversation of morality and he makes it funny and interesting and relatable. For example, there's a chapter titled, and by the way, all the chapter titles are hilarious, but here's one that cracked me up. There's a chapter titled, Do I Have to Return My Shopping Cart to the Shopping Cart Rack Thingy? It's All the Way Over There. Yes. And then basically what he does is he answers that question, and the answer is based on all of these ancient philosophers and, you know, ethics and morality and your moral compass. Yes. So, listen, I think we should
我就想，我还想读更多。我醒来时脑子里都在想它。你知道我的意思吗？所以，迈克是一位如此了不起的作家。我们已经知道了这一点，但他把这种关于道德的对话变得既有趣、引人入胜又贴近生活。例如，有一个章节的标题——顺便说一下，所有的章节标题都很搞笑，但有一个把我逗乐了。有一个章节的标题是：我必须把购物车送回购物车架子那里吗？它离得那么远耶。是的。然后基本上他做的是回答这个问题，而这个答案是基于所有这些古代哲学家，你知道的，还有伦理学、道德以及你的道德罗盘。是的。所以，听着，我觉得我们应该
take a break, and when we come back, you get to listen to Mike, sure. And we get to find out so much about Moe's. It's a treat, we promise. Mike, sure. Welcome to Office Ladies. Woohoo! I'm so excited to be here. I'm a huge fan of you as people, first of all, first and foremost. Second of all, you as actors. And then third of all, you as podcasters. This has been such a delight to watch you do this thing to celebrate this show that we all made together. I'm so happy to be here. It's a real honor. Oh, Mike, thank you so much. We love you. We're so thrilled to have you here, and I know the fans are going to enjoy just hearing your voice. Jen and I both listened to you quite
休息一下，等我们回来，你们就能听到迈克的访谈了。我们也能了解到关于莫斯的超多故事。这绝对是个福利，我们保证。迈克·舒尔，欢迎来到办公室女士。噢噢！我太高兴能来这里了。首先，也是最重要的，我是你们做人的超级粉丝。其次，是你们作为演员的粉丝。第三，是你们作为播客主持人的粉丝。看着你们做这件事来庆祝我们大家一起创作的节目，真是一种莫大的享受。我太高兴能来这里了。这真的是个很高的荣誉。噢，迈克，非常感谢你。我们太爱你了。你能来我们超级激动，我知道粉丝们也会很享受听到你的声音。珍娜和我在这之前都听了你挺
a bit before this, and we both found you really pleasing to listen to. Really? Yeah, we like your voice quite a lot. We like your voice. You listened to me in what context? Other podcasts, Mike. Our views, podcasts. We do our research here on Office Ladies. Yeah. It's very nice of you to say because I've always found my own voice to be slightly annoying, which I think maybe most people do. It's the phenomenon of hearing your voice played back to you. This is how old we are. It's like on an answering machine message or something. If you were, you'd be like, oh, is that what I sound like? I always feel
多节目的，我们都觉得你的声音听起来非常悦耳。真的吗？对，我们挺喜欢你的声音的。我们很喜欢你的声音。你们在什么语境下听我说话？其他播客，迈克。我们的浏览记录，播客。我们在《办公室女士》这里可是做了功课的。是的。你这么说真是太好了，因为我一直觉得我自己的声音稍微有点烦人，我想可能大多数人都会这么觉得。这就是听到自己的录音回放时的那种现象。这就是我们有多老了。就像在答录机留言里听到一样。如果你听到的话，你会想，哦，这就是我的声音听起来的样子吗？我总是觉得
like I sound a little annoying and nasally, but I'm glad to hear you say that. Well, I felt that way about myself too, and I sort of brushed it off like, oh, that's just everybody feels that way about their own voice. But then we recently re-watched an episode where Michael is trying to get Jim to say something bad about Pam, and he gets Jim to admit that Pam's voice is rather shrill sometimes, and I thought, oh, I guess maybe in the writer's room, when forced to come up with something annoying about me, we settled on my shrill voice. So thank you so much. Which writer hated your voice? I don't know.
我的声音听起来有点烦人、有点鼻音，但很高兴听到你们这么说。好吧，我对我也曾有过这种感觉，我当时有点不以为然地想，哦，每个人对自己的声音都有这种感觉。但我们最近重温了一集，迈克尔试图让吉姆说出帕姆的坏话，他让吉姆承认帕姆的声音有时相当刺耳，我想，哦，我想也许在编剧室里，当被迫想出关于我的烦人事时，我们就决定用我那刺耳的声音了。非常感谢你们。哪个编剧讨厌你的声音？我不知道。
I'm very pleased to say that I think I was gone by the time that was written, so I do not have to answer that crime. It wasn't you. Well played. No. It wasn't you. Well, listen, we always like to ask people when they come on the podcast, how did they get their job on the office? And we know that you did double duty. You were a writer, but then you were also a performer. But let's start with how did you get your job as a writer on the show? So I was writing at Saturday Night Live from 1998 to 2004. My then girlfriend, now wife of 16 years, had moved out to LA permanently in like 2002, and we were dating long distance.
我很高兴地说，我想写那一集的时候我已经离开了，所以我不需要为那个罪行回答。不是你。演得好。不。不是你。好吧，听着，我们总是喜欢问来到播客的嘉宾，他们是如何得到《办公室》的工作的？我们知道你身兼两职。你是一名编剧，但你同时也是一名演员。但我们先从你是如何得到这部剧的编剧工作的开始讲起吧？我从1998年到2004年在《周六夜现场》当编剧。我当时的女友、现在结婚16年的妻子，大约在2002年永久搬到了洛杉矶，我们开始了异地恋。
And in like 2003, it was like, all right, if this is ever going to really work, either she had to move back to New York, or I had to leave and move to LA, and it made more sense for me to move to LA because there are more jobs there. So I gave my like years notice to Lauren Michaels, and so I was leaving at the end of the year and got an agent for the first time in my life because I never needed one. And I was like, all right, I'm moving. And the first thing he told me was, you know, this guy, Greg Daniels is adapting the British office for American television. And I responded. What a terrible idea. It's just a disaster. You shouldn't do this. No one should do this
大概在2003年的时候，情况就变成了，好吧，如果这段感情想要真正修成正果，要么她得搬回纽约，要么我得离开并搬到洛杉矶，而搬到洛杉矶对我来说更合理，因为那里的工作更多。所以我向洛恩·迈克尔斯提前一年左右提出了辞职，因此我将在年底离开，并生平第一次找了个经纪人，因为我以前从不需要。我说，好吧，我要搬家了。他告诉我的第一件事是，你知道吗，这个叫格雷格·丹尼尔斯的人正在为美国电视翻拍英国的《办公室》。我的反应是。这真是个糟糕的主意。这简直是一场灾难。你不该这么做。任何人都不该这么做
because I was a huge fan of the British show. This is such a classic story, right? I was a huge fan of the British show. I thought it was absolutely brilliant. I didn't think there was any way you would ever work in America. But it was like, well, you know, beggars can't be choosers. Like, I have to get a job out there. So I came to LA some time in, I don't even remember like, or like winter, I think, like February on an off week at SNL. And I had a bunch of meetings and one of them was with Greg. So most of the meetings I had with producers were pretty standard, hour long chats. You know, hey, here's our here's our pilot, watch the pilot and let's talk about the show. And I dutifully tried to, you know, say nice
因为我是英国原版的超级粉丝。这是一个多么经典的故事，对吧？我是英国原版的超级粉丝。我觉得它绝对太精彩了。我不认为它有任何可能在美国行得通。但当时的想法是，人穷志不短嘛。总之我得去那边找工作。所以我大约在某个时候来到了洛杉矶，我甚至不记得具体是哪天了，大概是冬天，好像是二月份，正值《周六夜现场》的休播周。我开了好多会，其中一场就是和格雷格开的。我与其他制片人开的大多数会都相当标准，就是一小时左右的闲聊。你知道的，嘿，这是我们的试播集，看看试播集然后我们来聊聊这部剧。我非常尽责地试着，你知道的，说些好听的
things about whatever they were working on. And then I met with Greg and my meeting with Greg was two hours long, more than two hours long. And it was so different from every other meeting. It was, um, it was like intense and in depth and fascinating. In the middle of the meeting, he said, I'm very sorry, but my back is acting up. Would you mind if I lied down? And I said, no. And so he lay on the floor on his back in front of me while I sat on his couch. So I think to an outside observer, it would look very much like we were in like Freudian analysis where I was just therapist and he was like free associating. But he just asked the most incisive questions, the most penetrating questions about the nature
话来评价他们正在制作的东西。然后我遇到了格雷格，我和格雷格的会议持续了两小时，超过两个小时。它和所有其他的会议都太不一样了。它，呃，它既紧张、深入又迷人。开会开到一半，他说，非常抱歉，但我的背病犯了。你介意我躺一会儿吗？我说，不介意。于是他就躺在地板上，仰面躺在我面前，而我坐在他的沙发上。所以我想在局外人看来，这非常像我们在进行弗洛伊德式的心理分析，我只是个治疗师，而他在自由联想。但他只是提出了关于讲故事的本质最犀利的问题，最深刻的问题，
of storytelling and about the British show and why it worked and what he had to do to make it work here. And I left the meeting and I texted on my like Motorola razor. I texted my agent and I said, um, I don't know if that guy's going to offer me a job. But if he does I'm going to take it because I think he's going to teach me how to write. And, um, my agent, uh, sends me that text like every four years. Back to me. He sends it back to me and says like, you were right. You were right. You're right. Um, so, so Greg offered me the job. Um, and I happily took it and I thought this is obviously not going to work. Uh, it's a, it is a, um, it is a fool's errand to try to adapt this show for an American audience.
关于英国原版以及为什么它能成功，以及他必须做什么才能让它在这里成功。我离开会议后，用我的摩托罗拉刀锋手机发了一条短信。我给我的经纪人发短信说，呃，我不知道那家伙会不会录用我。但如果他录用了，我一定要接受，因为我觉得他要教我怎么写作。然后，呃，我的经纪人，呃，每隔四年就会把那条短信发给我。发回给我。他把它发回给我，说就像，你是对的。你是对的。你是对的。呃，所以，所以格雷格给了我这份工作。呃，我开心地接受了，而且我想这显然不会成功。呃，这是一个，呃，这是一个，
But he's going to teach me how to write. And that's exactly what happened. And that first season, you know, the only full-time writers really were me, Mindy and BJ because, um, Lester Lewis, the late Lester Lewis and Paul Eberstein and Larry Wilmore were consultants and Mindy and BJ and I had never written anything. We didn't have any idea what we were doing and Greg basically taught a class. He taught a, uh, like the true professor he is, he taught a class on how to write and, um, and it changed all of our lives forever. So that's my office origin story. Wow. That is so good. Mike, I remember you guys, um, that first season, there were so
试图为美国观众翻拍这部剧简直是白费力气。但他要教我怎么写作。而事实也的确如此。在第一季的时候，你知道，真正的全职编剧其实只有我和门迪还有BJ，因为，呃，已故的莱斯特·刘易斯、保罗·利伯斯坦和拉里·威尔莫尔是顾问，而门迪、BJ和我以前从来没写过任何东西。我们根本不知道自己在做什么，而格雷格基本上就像在上课。他上了一门，呃——就像他真正的教授风范一样——他上了一门关于如何写作的课，呃，这永远改变了我们所有人的生活。这就是我的《办公室》起源故事。哇。太棒了。迈克，我记得你们，呃，第一季的时候，你们只有
few of you and, um, how close you all became because of that. Yeah. It was a tiny little, Greg used to call it, uh, a strike force. He was like, this is an elite strike force, which I think was just him trying to boost our confidence because we had no idea what we were doing. Um, but it was really, you know, it was, it was a very, very small group of people who were working really, really hard on a very small number of episodes. So we only had, we only wrote five scripts. Like, um, you know, we each wrote, we, we actually wrote, uh, we wrote six to make five. I'm not sure if you remember this, but we wrote, or even if you even knew this, Greg, one of the only things
那么少的人，而且，呃，你们因为那段经历变得多么亲密。是的。那是一个很小的群体，格雷格以前称之为，呃，突击队。他说，这是一支精英突击队，我想这其实只是他在试图增强我们的信心，因为我们完全不知道自己在做什么。但真的，你知道的，那是一个非常非常小的群体，在一小部分剧集上付出了非常非常多的努力。所以我们只有，我们只写了五个剧本。就像，呃，你知道的，我们每个人都写了，我们实际上写了，我们写了六个来选出五个。我不确定你是否还记得这个，或者你甚至知不知道，格雷格，唯一的事情之一
that Greg was able to squeeze out of NBC in that first year was he let us write one more script than we would shoot. And so we wrote one extra episode, um, that I think he wrote. And then we just, we picked the best five out of the six that we had written and threw the other one away. And I wish I could remember what that other one was. There is a, there is a lost season one. Oh, that'd be a good question for Greg. Yeah. There's a lost season one office episode script out there somewhere that we just never, uh, that we never produced. Um, so it was, and it was like, you know, it was really intense
格雷格在第一季能够从NBC那里争取到的就是，他让我们多写了一个剧本，超过了我们要拍摄的数量。所以我们多写了一个额外的剧集，呃，我想那是他写的。然后我们只是从写好的六个剧本里挑出最好的五个，把另一个扔掉了。我真希望我能记起另一个是什么。有一个，有一个失落的第一季。哦，这会是个问格雷格的好问题。是的。外面某处有一个失落的第一季《办公室》剧集剧本，只是我们从来没有，呃，我们从来没有制作过。所以，那真是，而且就像，你知道的，那真的是非常紧张的工作，它结合了，
work and it was a combination of, of like story breaking, but also just like a master class in how to create television and what makes a good story. There were times when, I've told this story before, but there were times when Greg was talking, we would be pitching and I had a notebook where I would like just jot down ideas and there would be moments when Greg would say, um, well, let's talk about what, let's just pause for a second and talk about like what makes a good story. And then he would start kind of like going through the list of things that he felt were crucial to good TV stories. And I would realize like, oh, he's in lecture mode is the way I thought of it was lecture mode, which was
比如构思故事，但同时也是一堂关于如何创作电视以及是什么造就有好故事的大师课。有时，我以前讲过这个故事，但有时当格雷格在说话时，我们在构思提案，我有一个笔记本，我会把想法随手记下来，会有那么一些时刻格雷格会说，呃，好吧，我们来谈谈什么，让我们暂停一秒钟，谈谈什么造就了一个好故事。然后他就会开始像那样逐一列出他认为对好电视故事至关重要的东西。然后我会意识到，哦，他在讲课模式了，我当时就是这么认为的，讲课模式，这其实
a good thing. It sounds like a bad thing, but it was a good thing. And I would turn the page and I would start taking notes like I was in college and I would just like write down as if he were an actual professor and I had a test coming up and I would start just writing down and I still have those notes and I still go back and look at them every once in a while to like remember, to refresh my memory about what he told us all about storytelling. It was that intense and that sort of foundational and meaningful to all of us. Oh man.
是件好事。听起来像件坏事，但实际上是件好事。然后我会翻过那一页，开始做笔记，就像我在上大学一样，我会像对待一个真正的教授那样写下来，就好像我马上要考试一样，我会开始写下来，我至今还留着那些笔记，每隔一段时间我还会回去看看，为了记住，为了刷新我的记忆，关于他告诉我们所有关于讲故事的那些事。就是那么紧张，而且对我们所有人都具有那种奠基性的和深刻的意义。哦天哪。
Wow. I do remember those early days about what a small collective we were. Even our table reads, do you remember? We would just pull up chairs on the stage where we were filming. We would just all grab like a desk chair and sit in a circle and read the script. And I loved that. Yeah. It was really intimate. There were so many cool things about that first season, including that the place where
哇。我还记得那些早期的日子，我们是一个多么小的集体。甚至我们的剧本围读，你们还记得吗？我们就在我们拍摄的舞台上拉几把椅子。我们都会抓一把办公椅，围成一个圈坐下来读剧本。我太喜欢那样了。是的。非常亲密。第一季有那么多酷炫的事情，包括我们工作的地方
we worked was on this weird soundstage in the middle of Culver City or something. And so Hollywood soundstages are often these big, gigantic empty rooms where you put sets and then attached to them usually or above them are a suite of offices where the writers and the production staff works. But that suite of offices became the actual set. The set that we built was modeled on the crappy offices where the writers were working and right down to the layout. Greg was in what would be Michael's office and there was a reception desk right outside it that became Pam's reception desk. And so we would do these drills. Greg would have us do these drills where he would go like, okay, take a half an hour and go sit
在一个奇怪的录音棚里，位于卡尔弗城或者什么地方的中间。所以好莱坞的录音棚通常都是那种巨大无比的空房间，你在里面搭建布景，然后连接着它们的通常是或者在它们上方是一套办公室，编剧和制作人员在那里工作。但那套办公室成了真正的布景。我们搭建的布景就是按照编剧们工作的破烂办公室仿制的，连布局都一模一样。格雷格的办公室就是迈克尔的办公室，外面正对着一个前台，那成了帕姆的前台。所以我们会做这些训练。格雷格会让我们做这些训练，他会说，好了，花半小时去坐在
at Pam's desk or go sit in Michael's office or what will be Michael's office or go sit where Jim sits and just get a sense of what is your eye line to Pam. So he would put Mindy at Pam's reception desk and he would put BJ at Jim's desk. And he would say, just sit there and absorb the vibe of imagine that you're in love with that person and that you have to angle your chair in such a way so that you can catch a glimpse of her out of the corner of your eye or whatever. And it was fascinating. It was really interesting. And I remember at one point he had me go into work in Michael's office or what the office that would be the model for Michael's office. And I remember hating it because it was like
帕姆的桌子旁，或者坐在迈克尔的办公室里，或者将成为迈克尔办公室的地方，或者坐在吉姆坐的地方，去感受一下你对帕姆的视线是怎样的。所以他会让门迪坐在帕姆的前台，让BJ坐在吉姆的桌子旁。他会说，就坐在那里，吸收那种氛围，想象你爱上了那个人，你必须以某种角度摆放你的椅子，这样你才能从眼角余光瞥见她一眼，诸如此类。这太迷人了。真的非常有趣。我记得有一次他让我去在迈克尔的办公室里工作，或者说将成为迈克尔办公室模版的那个办公室。我记得我讨厌那样，因为就像
I was in this I was far away from everything and all this and I would see people talking through the windows and I'd be like, what are they talking about? And I had the urge to like go out and like do what Michael did all the time, which was like, Hey, what's going on? You know, like, and it was like he was just so he knew so much about what he wanted out of the show that he would he would practice not just the skill of writing the characters, but the the skill of like embodying them or emotionally connecting to them. And it was just that's what I mean when I say it was professorial. It was it wasn't just like, all right, what's episode two? What's the act break? What's the first act
我身处其中，我离所有东西都很远，而且我会透过窗户看到人们在聊天，我会想，他们在聊什么呢？我有种冲动想走出去，像迈克尔平时那样做，就是，嘿，怎么啦？你知道吗，而且就像他太清楚了，他非常清楚自己想从这部剧中得到什么，所以他不仅会练习塑造角色的技巧，还会练习如何具象化他们或与他们建立情感联系的技巧。这就是我所说的教授风范的意思。这不只是说，好吧，第二集是什么？幕间休息是什么？季终集的第一个幕间休息是什么？而是真的像，我们必须具象化这些角色，在情感上和社会上去理解他们，我认为这最终造就了伟大的剧集，你知道的。嗯，这太有趣了，因为当所有演员到齐后，他们也对我们做了同样的事。他们让我们坐在桌子前，就坐在那里去感受它。我们以前讨论过这个。所以我很喜欢这种做法从你们写剧本的时候就开始了。
break for the for the season finale? It was really like, we had to embody the characters and understand them emotionally and and and socially in a way that I think led to great episodes, you know, Well, it's so interesting because when all the actors got there, then they did that to us too. They made us sit at our desks and just sit there and feel it. We've talked about that before. And so I love that that started all the way back with you guys writing the episodes. Yeah, June of June of 2004, like they're right from the from the jump. There were things
是的，2004年6月，就像从一开始一样。我们做过诸如此类的事情，这并不是与编剧团队一起工作时会做的典型事情。他经常做的另一件事，我觉得非常聪明，我现在在我工作的节目中也还在用，就是有一天我们来上班，他会把所有角色的名字写在一块板上，然后随机挑选两个。把它们交给我和拉里·威尔莫尔，说去为奥斯卡和凯利想五个故事创意。然后，然后你，门迪和保罗，去为，你知道的，吉姆和斯坦利想五个故事创意。然后在一个小时里，我们就只是构思提案。好吧，奥斯卡和凯利能有什么鬼故事？
like that that we did that weren't that weren't the typical things that you would do with the writing staff. Another thing he did all the time, which I thought was so smart, which I still do on shows that I work on now, is we would come into work one day and he would go he would have he would put all the characters names on a board and he would pick two of them at random. And he would give them to he would say me and Larry Wilmore like, go come up with five story ideas for Oscar and Kelly. And then and then you, Mindy and Paul like, go come up with five story ideas for, you know, Jim and Stanley. And it for an hour, we would just pitch. Okay, well, what the hell could a story be with Oscar and Kelly?
但这引出了一些非常酷的东西。就像前几季中的一些B线故事和C线故事，都来自于头脑风暴，比如将人们随机配对，他从根本上理解，该剧相对于其他剧集的一大优势在于我们有20个人，我们有——大多数剧集只有大概六个主要角色什么的。所以很快，你会对涉及这两个人或这三个人的故事感到厌倦。而他却说，这不是我们要做的。这部剧的重点是要像人类学家一样去观察大量人在同一办公室环境中的来来往往。所以，去研究随机配对吧，有时真的会有很有趣的东西诞生，你知道的，他就是如此透彻地理解是什么让这部剧变得特别，以及它能有多好的潜力，以至于他有所有这些筹划，他总是和编剧们在早期日子里在棋盘上移动棋子，你知道的。
But it led to some really cool stuff. And like some of those some of the little the B stories and the C stories of that came that were in the first couple of seasons were just brainstorming, like random pairings of people, he he understood fundamentally that one of the great advantages that the show had over other shows is that we had 20 people, we had like most shows have whatever, six main characters or something. And so pretty quickly, you get tired of a story with involving these two people or these three people. And he was like, that's not what this is going to be. This is going to be a the whole point of the shows to observe like an anthropologist observe the comings and goings of a large number of
是的，我记得我告诉我爸，我试图向我爸描述这群人和这部剧，他根本不搞娱乐行业，你知道的，他是一名钻井工程师。但有时我们能聊聊体育。我说，爸，情况是这样的。我们板凳深度很厚。这就像是一个篮球术语，就像我们的团队太棒了。这个团队有很多层次。然后当他来的时候，你知道的，格雷格邀请他们在午餐时的剧本围读中坐下来。我爸就说，我懂了。我现在懂了。是的，我懂了。就像会有笑声，我想是从他身上以及所有这些地方传来的，你知道的。是的。嗯，我要说的是，在第九季中，约翰和我被邀请成为该剧的制片人，来帮助敲定吉姆和帕姆的最后一季。我们得以进入他们的编剧室，主要作为观察员。而格雷格那一季还在运作这部剧。他仍然在做那些练习。这太迷人了。只是在这种情况下，它更像是家庭作业。我记得一天开始时格雷格说，
people and in the same office environment. So like, go work on random pairings and like sometimes really fun stuff would come out of it, you know, like, he just so thoroughly understood what what made the show special and what the potential was for how good it could be that he had all of these machinations and he was moving always moving pieces around the chessboard with the writers in those for in those early days, you know. Yeah, I remember telling my dad I was trying to describe this group of people and the show to my dad who was not at all in entertainment, you know, he's a drilling engineer. But sometimes we could talk sports. And I said, dad, here's the deal. We have a deep bench. And it's like
好了，拿你们的家庭作业出来。家庭作业是每个人都必须想出五个关于——我不记得是什么了，但就像是关于德怀特和斯坦利的冷开场，开始。然后你就会坐着听。然后当有一个激起他兴趣的想法时，哦，哦，好吧，你们两个去那边，把这个丰满起来。然后两个人就会离开房间。然后我们继续听家庭作业。我，我记得当时想，天哪，我要是得展示我的五个想法，我肯定吓死了。因为有时房间里一片死寂，就像你能听到那些想法在房间里直接死掉一样。我的天，在一群都在评判你是否应该顺着那个思路往下走的人面前展示你的创意想法，是一件多么紧张且脆弱的事情啊。是的，他最大的优点之一是，我想说，他不害怕失败。而且我认为，我相信这部分来自于在《周六夜现场》工作的经历，因为你刚才描述的那些提出想法却遭到惨败的情形，对吧，那就是在SNL工作的精髓，除了你在SNL的失败是公开的，比如你写了短剧，然后和该剧的所有演员、洛恩以及所有制片人围着一张巨大的桌子进行围读。而台下有100或150名在节目组工作的人。顺便说一句，还有一个非常著名的客串主持人在节目里，比如，你知道的，德雷克正在读你的短剧或者别的什么。在SNL会有这样的时刻，
a basketball term like our team is so good. There's so many layers to this team. And and then when he came and, you know, Greg invited them to sit at a table read at lunch. My dad was like, I get it. I get it now. Yeah, I get it. Like there were laughs, I think coming from him and all these places, you know. Yeah. Well, I was going to say that in season nine, John and I were invited to be producers on the show to kind of help carve out Jim and Pam's final season. And we got to come into their writers room, mostly as observers. And Greg was running the show that season. And he was still doing those exercises. And it was fascinating. Except in this case, it was more like homework. I remember the day started and Greg said,
你知道的，你的短剧有12页长什么的。然后你的短剧开始了，你读到了第二页，结果短剧的笑话抖出来了，却没有人笑。而在你的脑子里，你会想，还有10页呢。我们还得在这儿坐10分钟，因为没有人觉得我的设定好笑。所以对于前几个月，我不知道格雷格的经历是什么，我从没真正和他聊过他在那里的时光。但对于前六个月左右，你会陷入深深的抑郁。那种公开失败的方式太尴尬了。然后一周过去了，节目播出了。然后就像，好吧，又是星期一，再来一次。然后你就像那样再来一次，又失败了，失败了，失败了，失败了，失败了，最终，在某个时刻，希望你能摸索出门道。你写了一个短剧，引发了一些笑声。然后你会想，好吧，世界还没有毁灭，我还在这里。然后你变得稍微好一点，再好一点。那个，那种理论，对你的自我意识相当残酷。但当你已经在SNL的工作中把这种玻璃心磨灭掉了之后，比如五个斯坦利的冷开场，我能——谁在乎呢？是的，没错。所以，这和他的理论其实是：这是一场数字游戏，通往最佳想法的方法是你必须创造一千个想法，才能找到那两个好的。他对待所有事情都采取这种态度。他招募编剧时是这种态度，他选角时也是这种态度。
okay, get out your homework. And the homework had been that everyone had to come up with five ideas for I can't remember what it was, but it was like for a Dwight and Stanley cold open, go. And and then you would just sit and listen. And then when there was an idea that peaked his interest, he would say, oh, oh, okay, you two go off, flesh that out. And then two people would leave the room. And then we would keep listening to the homework. And I, I remember thinking, oh, my gosh, I would be so terrified to present my five ideas. Because sometimes it was just crickets, like you could just hear the ideas just die in the room. I mean, what an intense and vulnerable thing to pitch your creative ideas in front of like a room of people who are all judging whether
我的意思是，选角过程持续了多久？为了这部剧，漫长得无休止，漫长，漫长得无休止。而这只是他的作风，说到这一点，他绝对是最彻底的人，他绝不妥协，他要求你走到头。我的意思是，当我们在，当我们在，当我们在构思故事时，我们会在构思故事的过程中推进了五分之四。然后我们会到达一个他发现行不通的点，甚至会说，天哪，这行不通，扔掉，从头开始。这真的很累人，但这部剧也确实播了10年。而且真的很好。所以。而我们现在还在谈论它。是的，exactly。是的。17年后。好吧，现在我想我们得问问你，迈克。
or not you should follow that thread. Yes, one of his greatest strengths is that he is unafraid, I would say, of failure. And I think I believe that that comes, I'm guessing that that comes partially from working at Saturday Night Live, because what you just described of like pitching ideas and and having them bomb, right, that is the essence of working at SNL, except your failures at SNL are public, like you write sketches, and there's a read through with the entire cast of the of the show and Lauren and all the producers around a giant table. And the audience is 100 and or 150 people who work on the show. And by the way, a very famous person who's hosting the show, like, you know, Drake is reading your sketch or whatever. And you there are moments at SNL
是的，我们得问。你是怎么演上莫斯的？是的。我们听说你很讨厌这个角色。你讨厌当莫斯，但我们超爱莫斯。让我，让我，让我在这里明确地划清界限，这很重要。我很喜欢我演过莫斯这件事。我只是讨厌实际去演它，原因有两个。所以，故事是这样的。故事是，在，格雷格一直将德怀特·舒尔特背景设定的一部分是，他自己并不是阿米什人，或者门诺派教徒之类的，但他有点接近阿米什人，他有一些亲戚。他是日耳曼裔，他生活在宾夕法尼亚州的日耳曼后裔，光是这一点就有点接近阿米什人了。所以格雷格脑海深处一直觉得有一个表亲，一个舒尔特表亲
where, you know, your sketches are 12 pages long or whatever. And your sketch starts and you get to page two and like the joke of the sketch is sprung and no one laughs. And in your head, you're like, there's 10 more pages. Like we have to sit here for 10 more pages as no one finds my premise funny. And so for the first, I don't know what Greg's experience was, I've never really talked to him about his time there. But for the first like six months, you, it's, you fall into a deep depression. Like it's just like, it's so embarrassing to fail that way publicly. And then the week goes by and the show happens. And then it's like, all right, it's Monday again, do it again. And you like do it again, and you fail again, and you fail, and you fail, and you fail,
农场社区，要么是阿米什人，要么是阿米什家族的某种人。所以在2004年，有一个真人秀节目叫做《城里的阿米什人》。是的。是的。我看过那个。是的。那真是一个糟糕透顶的节目。看它太痛苦了。太糟糕了。我和我妻子看了那个节目，有一天我在编剧室里试着表达这个节目有多尴尬。节目的设定是，他们找了一群来自洛杉矶、正值春假的不学无术的夜店咖，然后对他们说，你们要去好莱坞山上这座超赞的房子里住，他们兴奋极了，心想我们要喝个大醉、疯狂派对什么的。他们不知道的是，同样被邀请住在房子里的，还有一群
and eventually, at some point, hopefully, you kind of figure it out. And you write a sketch and it gets some laughs. And you're like, okay, it's not the end of the world, like I'm still here. And then you get a little better and a little better. And that, like, that theory is, it's pretty brutal on your ego. But when you've already had it driven out of your ego from working at SNL, like five, five Stanley cold opens, I can, who cares? Yeah, exactly. So I that and his theory is really like, this is a numbers game, like the way to get to the best ideas is you have to create a thousand ideas in order to find the two that are good. And he took that approach with everything. He took that approach when he was hiring writers, he took that approach when he was casting people.
正在经历“青春期自由探索期”（Rumspringa）的年轻阿米什人，他们被放出来进行为期一年的探索，他们要住在一起，然后，你知道的，一团糟接踵而至，绝对是一团糟。对吧。所以节目中的其中一个阿米什人名叫莫斯，莫斯是个讨人喜欢、心地善良、脆弱得像鸡蛋一样的人，他尽最大努力想和那群来自洛杉矶的不学无术的夜店咖交朋友，他尝试的方法之一就是自己亲手制作木制玩具，比如一个小小的木制飞机或一架小木车，然后——像礼物一样，是他自己做的。他自己亲手做的，然后把它送给他的新朋友们，而他们的反应却是，这特么是什么鬼？对吧。所以我当时正在向房间里的其他人讲述这个故事，
I mean, how long did the casting process go on? For for the show, endlessly long, endlessly, endlessly long. And that's just his, he's just the most thorough person when it comes to that he doesn't settle for anything he, he demands that you walk down. I mean, when we're, when we're, when we were breaking stories, like, we would get five sixth of the way down the line toward breaking a story. And we'd get to a point where he would realize it didn't work and even go like, man, this doesn't work, throw it away, start over. And it's really exhausting, but also the show lasted for 10 years. And it was really good. So. And here we are still talking about it. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. 17 years later. Well, now I think we have to ask you, Mike.
讲这个节目有多糟糕，然后格雷格用他巨大的手指指着我。我记得太清楚了。他说，你要演莫斯。你是德怀特的表亲。你就是莫斯。然后我说，哈哈哈哈。然后他说，不，我是认真的。我们要这么做。你要演莫斯。我以为这只是个玩笑，原因有几个。首先，因为我以为这是个玩笑。其次，因为所有其他的编剧，正如你们可能知道的，基本上都扮演了他们自己的某种版本，或者是剧中的重要角色，比如门迪一直都在剧中，保罗一直都在剧中，BJ也一直都在剧中。而格雷格基本上是在说，你是个笑话。我要把你变成一个笑话。然后，所以第一次
Yeah, we do. How did you come to play Mo's? Yeah. Something we understand you hated. You hated being Mo's, but we love Mo's. Let me, let me, let me be just delineate here, importantly. I love the fact that I played Mo's. I hated actually doing it because for two reasons. So, so here's the story. The story was in the, in the, Greg always had it as part of Dwight Schrute's backstory that he, he himself was not Amish or, or Mennonite or anything like that, but he was sort of Amish adjacent that he had relatives. He was a Germanic, he was of Germanic descent living in Pennsylvania that is, that's, that alone is sort of Amish adjacent. So Greg always had it in the back of his head that there was a sort of cousin, a Schrute cousin
我们拍的时候，是在一张照片里。就是雷恩说，我有一个表亲。我和我的表亲莫斯一起经营一家甜菜农场。那是在我写的一集里。就是迈克尔买公寓的那集。是的。那只是一张照片。我想，太好了。我会戴上假胡子。其实，我甚至觉得拍那张照片时我连胡子都没有，但我会穿上这些羊毛衣服，拍张照片，那就结束了。但后来编剧们——我所谓的“朋友们”——对我扮演莫斯感到非常兴奋，开始不断把我的戏份写进剧集里。就是BJ写的那集，德怀特试图通过带瑞安去他的农场，将瑞安引入某种销售员兄弟会。他们把莫斯写进了
farming community that was, that was either Amish or something in the Amish family. So so there in, in 2004, there was a reality show called Amish in the City. Yes. Yes. I saw that. Yes. It was a terrible, terrible program. It was so hard to watch. It was so awful. And I, my wife and I watched it and I was sort of trying to express how cringy it was to the writer's room one day. The premise of the show was they took a bunch of idiot club kids from LA who were on spring break and they were like, you guys are going to come stay in this awesome house in the Hollywood Hills and they were psyched and they were like, we're going to get so drunk and party and whatever. What they didn't know that also invited to stay in the house were a bunch of
剧中。所以格雷格坚持要求这一集我必须留真胡子。他认为假胡子据他看来不会显得真实。我说，听吧，我长面部毛发可不容易。这需要花我很长时间。他说，好吧，那你最好赶紧开始。这基本上就是一种整蛊。这就是全部。所以我为了这个接连几个月留了真胡子。在那期间，这部剧获得了一项艾美奖。格雷格和我还有其他一些制片人四处奔走，参加了好多花哨的好莱坞活动。在每一张照片里，我都留着那个恶心、干硬的莫斯胡子。然后那一集本该是我们在第三季拍摄的第一集。但后来有个——我记不清为什么了，有一些
young Amish folks on Rum Springer who had been released for their year of exploration and they were going to live together and hot and then, you know, hot mess ensues, hot, hot, hot mess ensues. Right. So one of the characters on the show who was Amish was named Moes and Moes was this delightful, kind-hearted, fragile egg who would tried his best to become friends with the idiot club kids from LA and among other ways that he tried this where he fashioned his own wooden toys, like little, like a little wooden airplane or a little wooden car and like present, like he made them himself. He made them himself and he presented them to his new friends and they were just like, what the hell is this? Right. And so I was like relating this story to the room about
制作方面的问题还是剧本问题什么的。它被推迟了两三个月。我意识到，我记得那种大汗淋漓的恐慌，我在倒计时数着日子等着刮胡子。然后我想，哦不，现在我不能刮胡子，然后又不能及时把胡子重新留起来。所以我不得不又留了三个月。等我们终于拍完那一集时，大概是9月中旬，正值圣费尔南多谷深处那个迪斯尼牧场山谷外景地，我们在那里拍摄雷恩的德怀特农场。我们拍那第一集的那天，最高气温是105华氏度（约40.5摄氏度）。而我穿着长毛衣内衣、羊毛裤、羊毛衬衫、背带，还有一双极其不舒服的旧工作靴。我不得不跑来跑去
how like awful this show was and Greg pointed at me with his giant finger. I remember it so clearly and said, you're going to play Moes. You're Dwight's cousin. You're going to be your Moes. And I was like, ha, ha, ha. And he was like, no, I'm serious. We're going to do this. You're going to play Moes. And I thought it was a joke for a couple of reasons. First, because I thought it was a joke. Second, because all of the other writers, as you may know, got to play essentially like versions of themselves or significant characters in the show, like Mindy was in the show all the time and Paul was in the show all the time and BJ was in the show all the time. And Greg was essentially saying, you are a joke. I'm going to turn you into a joke. And then so the first time
这个节目有多糟糕，格雷格用他巨大的手指指着我。我记得太清楚了，他说，你要演莫斯。你是德怀特的表弟。你要演莫斯。当时我还想，哈哈，哈哈。他却说，不，我是认真的。我们要这么做。你要演莫斯。我以为这只是个玩笑，原因有好几个。首先，因为我以为这只是个玩笑。其次，因为你知道，所有其他的编剧都基本上演的是他们自己，或者是剧中的重要角色，比如敏迪经常在剧里，保罗也经常在剧里，BJ也经常在剧里。而格雷格的意思基本上是，你就是一个笑话。我要把你变成一个笑话。然后所以第一次
that we did it, it was in a photo. It was when Raine just says, I have a cousin. I run a beat farm with my cousin Moes. It was in an episode I wrote. It was the one where Michael buys a condo. Yes. And it was just a photo. And I was like, great. I'll put on a fake beard. And actually, I don't even think I had the beard for the photo, but I'll dress up in these wool clothes and we'll take a photo and that'll be the end of it. But then the writers, my so-called friends, got very excited about me playing Moes and started writing me into episodes all the time. And it was the episode BJ wrote where the initiation where Dwight was trying to initiate Ryan into some kind of salesman fraternity by bringing him to his farm. And they wrote Moes into the
我们拍的时候，是在一张照片里。那是雷恩说，我有个表弟。我和我表弟莫斯经营一个甜菜农场。那是在我写的一集里。就是迈克尔买公寓那一集。对。那只是一张照片。当时我想，太好了。我要戴上假胡子。其实，我觉得拍那张照片时我甚至还没胡子，不过我会穿上这些羊毛衣服，我们拍张照片，这事就过去了。但后来，编剧们，也就是我所谓的“朋友”们，对由我来演莫斯感到非常兴奋，开始不断把我的角色写进剧集里。那是BJ写的那集，讲的是德怀特试图通过把瑞安带到他的农场，来让瑞安加入某种推销员兄弟会。他们把莫斯写进了
show. And so Greg insisted for this episode that I have a real beard. He didn't believe that a fake beard, according to him, would look real. And I was like, listen, I don't grow facial hair very easily. It's going to take me a long time. He's like, well, you better get started. It was basically just hazing. That's all it was. So I grew a real beard for months and months and months. And in that time, this show was nominated for an Emmy. And Greg and I and some of the other producers went around and had a bunch of like fancy Hollywood events that we went to. And in every one of those photos, I have the disgusting, wiry Moes beard. And then so that episode was supposed to be the first one we shot that in season three. But then there was a I can't remember why there was some
剧中。因此，格雷格坚持要求我在这一集里留真胡子。他认为假胡子按他的标准看起来不会像真的。我就说，听着，我很难长出面部毛发。这需要很长时间。他说，好吧，那你最好赶紧开始。这基本上就是一种整蛊。完全就是这样。于是我花了几个月又几个月的时间留了真胡子。就在这段时间里，这部剧获得了艾美奖提名。我和格雷格还有其他一些制片人四处参加了许多高档的好莱坞活动。在每一张照片里，我都顶着那副恶心、硬邦邦的莫斯胡子。然后，那一集本该是我们在第三季拍摄的第一集。但后来，我记不清为什么了，出了一些
kind of production issue or script issue or something. And it got delayed like two or three more months. And I realized like, I remember like this sweating panic of like, I was counting down the days until I could shave. And I was like, Oh, no, now I can't shave now and then grow the beard back in time. So I had to keep it like another three months. And then by the time we finally shot it, it was like mid September in deep in the valley on that Disney Ranch Valley location where we shot Reigns, Dwight's Farm. It was the day we shot that first episode, the high that day was 105. And I was wearing long johns and wool pants and a wool shirt and suspenders and these old work boots that were incredibly uncomfortable. And I had to run around
诸如制作问题或剧本问题之类的事情。拍摄推迟了两三个月。我意识到，我记得那种大汗淋漓的恐慌感，就像我在倒计时，盼着能刮胡子。我当时想，噢，不，现在我还不能刮胡子，然后到时候再把胡子长回来。所以我不得不又留了三个月。等到我们终于拍完那一集时，已经是九月中旬了，正值我们在雷恩的德怀特农场取景拍摄的那个迪士尼牧场山谷的最深处。我们拍第一集那天，最高气温达到了105华氏度。我穿着秋裤、羊毛裤、羊毛衬衫、背带裤，还有一双极其不舒服的老旧工装靴。我不得不四处奔跑
and and pretend to wrestle Ryan and like, I was just like, I was like a ghost, like I was just like running through I was like a horror movie ghost running through the background of scenes. It took an entire day. I had to get up at 430 in the morning to get to Disney Ranch by 530. And I was like, Well, at least I'll never have to do that again. And then the writers, my so called friends, wrote me into like a hundred more episodes. So I I'm I'm very honored and happy to have played a small silly role in the in the history of the show on screen. But the actual act of doing it was always 105. They always I was always shirtless on a seesaw or running alongside a car like a dog. Or in in probably the scariest moment of my life, being slapped,
然后假装和瑞安摔跤，我就像个幽灵一样，在场景背景里穿梭，就像恐怖片里的鬼魂一样。这花了一整天。我不得不早上4点半起床，5点半赶到迪士尼牧场。当时我想，好吧，至少我再也不用经历这种事了。然后编剧们，也就是我所谓的“朋友们”，又给我安排了上百集戏。所以，对于能在该剧的历史和荧幕中扮演一个小小的、滑稽的角色，我感到非常荣幸和高兴。但实际去演的时候，总是105码的难度。我总是赤裸上身坐在跷跷板上，或者像狗一样在车旁奔跑。或者经历了我一生中可能最恐怖的时刻——挨了一记耳光。
like, like being punched in the face, essentially, by Angela Kinsey, you know, that was one of the most terrifying moments of my life. Do you remember that? Yes, yes, I was going to talk to you about it because Angela and Moes had so many actual scenes together. And a lot of them are in the deleted scenes. I'm watching the DVDs. Some made it in. But, you know, a few really cracked me up. And but I have to talk to you about that one. First, I want to say there was a deleted scene in the surplus where I'm at Shroop Farms with Andy. We're wedding planning Dwight is our wedding planner. We're trying to discuss a butter sculpture and Andy's signing all these papers and you're coming in the kitchen. And I his at you.
基本上就像被安吉拉·金西狠狠地打在脸上，你知道，那是我一生中最恐怖的时刻之一。你还记得吗？记得，记得，我正想跟你聊这个，因为安吉拉和莫斯有很多实际的对手戏。其中很多都被剪掉了。我正在看DVD。有些保留了下来。但是，你知道，有几个片段真的让我笑喷了。不过我得跟你聊聊那场戏。首先我想说的是，《盈余》里有一段被删掉的片段，当时我和安迪在施鲁特农场。我们在筹备婚礼，德怀特是我们的婚礼策划人。我们正试图讨论一个黄油雕塑，安迪在签一堆文件，然后你走进厨房。我冲你发出嘶嘶声。
Like a cat. And then you run away. And we kept breaking at this because it was so absurd. So there's that that moment. Like, what? What is Angela and Moes? What is their relationship? But then the episode he's talking about, I want to look because I wrote it. It's the finale. It's the series finale. No, that's when you kidnapped me. Oh, right, right, right. There, no. Okay, the episode was free family portrait. And Angela is chasing who she thinks is Dwight and Dwight's car. But it's Moes dressed as Dwight because she wants to find out if Dwight's found out about her baby, right? Right, right. And one of the things I remember, which is crazy in hindsight, Mike, is that you and I did our own stunt driving where we had to screech into a cul-de-sac and pull
像猫一样。然后你跑开了。我们一直在笑场，因为这太荒谬了。所以有这样一个时刻。安吉拉和莫斯到底是什么情况？他们的关系是什么？但接下来他说的那集，我想查一下，因为是我写的。那是大结局。是剧集大结局。不，那是你绑架我的那一集。哦，对，对，对。那集，不。好吧，那一集是《全家福》。安吉拉在追她以为是德怀特的车，但开车的其实是打扮成德怀特的莫斯，因为她想查清楚德怀特是不是已经知道了她孩子的事，对吧？对，对。我记得的一件事，现在回想起来觉得太疯狂了，迈克，就是你和我亲自上阵进行特技驾驶，我们必须发出刺耳的刹车声冲进死胡同，然后停成。
side by side, like really fast turn on a dime. And then I fly out of the car because they didn't want to waste any time, lose all that footage. And I run up and I swing open the door and it's Moes and not Dwight. And you won't tell me where Dwight is. And they wanted me to slap the shit out of you. Right. So what happened was we were like, okay, you and I just were like, so let's just like walk through how this happens. And you were kind of like, okay, so I'll come over here and then I'll get out here and you'll stand against the car and then I'll slap you. And you like just sort of moved your hand. I did a fakey. You did a fakey. And I was like, okay, yeah, this seems okay. So we do the first take, we screech up, we do a good job of doing our own stunts,
并排停下，车速极快，原地转弯。然后我从车里飞出来，因为他们不想浪费任何时间，不想失去所有这些镜头。我跑过去，猛地拉开车门，发现里面是莫斯而不是德怀特。而且你不肯告诉我德怀特在哪儿。他们想让我狠狠地扇你一巴掌。对。所以情况是这样的，我们当时想，好吧，你和我就像这样，让我们来排练一下这个过程是怎么发生的。然后你大概说，好吧，那我到这里来，然后我从这儿出去，你靠着车站好，然后我扇你。然后你就随便挥了下手。我做了一个假动作。你做了一个假动作。然后我说，好吧，嗯，这看起来还行。于是我们拍了第一个镜头，我们尖叫着停下，我们自己完成了特技动作，
by the way. Yeah. You pull me out, you're like, where's Dwight? Where's Dwight? I'm like, I don't know or something or something. And then you slap me, but you slapped me for real. You hit me so hard, I spun around like a top and like hit the roof of the car and was like, my ears were ringing. And I remember like, I was like, oh, I can't hear what she's saying to me because my ear is ringing so loudly. I'm so sorry. You know, Matt Sohn told me, he was like, Angela, you're gonna have to really hit him because we're pretty wide. It'll be, you won't be able to do the fakey. Yes. And I also remember this is not your fault. None of this is your fault. I feel so bad I felt like that. No, because I remember saying, no, really hit me, because I'm six feet tall. You are not six feet tall. I am five one. Right.
顺便说一句。对。你把我拽出来，你问，德怀特在哪儿？德怀特在哪儿？我说，我不知道或者随便什么。然后你扇我，但你是来真的。你打得我太狠了，我像陀螺一样转了个圈，还撞到了车顶上，当时我的耳朵一直在嗡嗡作响。我记得当时我心想，哦，我听不清她对我说什么了，因为我的耳鸣声太大了。真对不起。你知道，马特·索恩跟我说，他当时说，安吉拉，你得狠狠地打他，因为我们的镜头比较广。这样才行，你没法做假动作。是的。我也记得这不是你的错。这绝对不是你的错。我感到很抱歉，我当时觉得。不，因为我记得我说过，不，真的打我，因为我有六英尺高。你才没有六英尺高。我只有五尺一寸。对。
And I was like, no, I've, I hate it when there's like a fake slap on TV. I'm sure this will be fine. Just, just really hit me. It'll be fine. I remember telling you that, like just really hit me. It'll be fine. It'll be fine. I had no idea that you were a mixed martial arts professional and you hit me so hard. I really like lost my, I did not know where I was. I didn't know what was happening. I, my eyes went blank and my hearing dropped out and I had no idea what was happening. It was wonderful. I'm so, it, it, and that's the take they used, thankfully, because afterwards also, I remember afterwards, you were like, oh my God, I'm so sorry. And I was like, no, no, no, I just didn't understand how strong you were. Oh my gosh. Muggers beware. Okay.
然后我说，不，我，我讨厌电视里那种假打的耳光。我相信这会没事的。就，就狠狠地打我吧。会没事的。我记得我跟你说过，就像真的打我一样。会没事的。会没事的。我根本不知道你是个综合格斗专业人士，你打得我太狠了。我真的有点不知所措，我不知道自己在哪里。我不知道发生了什么。我的大脑一片空白，听力也下降了，我完全不知道发生了什么。这太棒了。我很，它，幸亏导演用的就是那个镜头，因为事后我也记得，事后你说，哦天哪，真的非常对不起。而我说，不，不，不，只是我没意识到你力气这么大。哦，天哪。歹徒小心了。好了。
Angela, Kinsey. I do remember, I felt so bad. And I remember saying, I was trying to like think, why, why, why was that so hard? Maybe it was the momentum because I'm running. I was like, trying to like think about, I don't know where the ninja came from, Mike. I think that slapping is just like a more shocking thing than youth. I've never been slapped in my life. I'm proud to say. And so I, I think I just greatly underestimated the force of the blow that was about to, about to hit my face. But this is, this is all part of this larger conversation of why it wasn't fun to play Moe's. It's because not only was it always a site gag, but also like the, sometimes the writers would write actual lines for me. And then in the edit, it would
安吉拉·金西。我确实记得，我当时感觉太糟糕了。我记得我在想，为什么，为什么，为什么那一巴掌打得那么重？也许是因为我奔跑时的惯性吧？我当时就在想，我不知道那个忍者是从哪里冒出来的，迈克。我觉得挨耳光比使用暴力更让人震惊。我这辈子从来没挨过耳光。我很自豪地说。所以，我想我大大低估了即将打在我脸上的那一巴掌的威力。但这只是那场长期讨论的一部分，即为什么扮演莫斯一点都不好玩。因为不仅总是一个视觉笑话，而且有时编剧会为我写一些实际的台词。然后剪辑的时候，它。
always be like, yeah, it's funny if we don't hear from Moe's, right? So it would cut all the lines. And then it was like, what is the most humiliating way that we can use him? And it was like being slapped be like in an outhouse with his pants around his ankles while the door is slamming closed. Like it was just, it was Greg's and the writer's way of just like enjoying tormenting me. So now when I look back, I'm, it's, I'm so happy that I did it. But at every time I had to like leave the writer's room, a place where I knew what I was doing and go be a performer where I did not know what I was doing. I was always a little bit like, this is a, this is torture. I always felt like it was a little bit of torture. Mike, do you get recognized for being Moe's very often?
总是会变成：是的，如果我们听不到莫斯的声音，会更好笑，对吧？所以所有的台词都被剪掉了。然后就变成了：我们能用什么最羞辱人的方式来捉弄他？比如挨耳光，或者被关在漏夜茅厕里，裤子褪到脚踝，门猛地关上。这只是格雷格和编剧们享受折磨我的方式。所以现在回想起来，我非常高兴我演了这个角色。但每当我不得不离开编剧室——那个我知道自己在做什么的地方，去当一个我不知道自己在做什么的表演者时，我总是有点觉得：这简直是折磨。我一直觉得这有点像折磨。迈克，你经常因为扮演莫斯而被认出来吗？
There are certainly times when I am recognized for that. Yes. I mean, I'm older, I'm, I'm 17 years older and my hair is a lot grayer. And so people don't, uh, don't recognize me as often as you would think they would given how popular the show still is. I will say that like my son went to a basketball camp a couple of summers ago and, uh, I went to pick him up from the camp and, uh, my son had just watched the show. I think he was 10 or 11 and he had just watched the whole show and he was very excited to tell people that I wrote for it and that I played Moe's. And, um, so I went to pick him up from the camp and one of his counselors, I walked over to where the kids were and one of his counselors saw me coming and he just broke into this huge smile and was like,
当然也有被认出来的时候。是的。我是说，我老了，我比以前老了17岁，头发也白了很多。所以人们不像你想象的那样经常认出我来，尽管这部剧现在依然很受欢迎。我要说的是，我儿子前几年夏天参加了一个篮球训练营，我去营地接他，我儿子刚刚看过这部剧。我想他当时10岁或11岁，他刚看完整部剧，非常兴奋地告诉别人我为这部剧写过剧本，而且我还演了莫斯。所以，我去营地接他，他的一个辅导员，我走到孩子们待的地方，他的辅导员看到我走过来，脸上立刻露出了灿烂的笑容，然后说：
hey, and I was like, all right, this guy knows that I was Moe's and like, you know, he's gonna tell when people recognize me. I did also, when the pandemic first hit, uh, I, I did a fundraiser for, uh, LA Regional Food Bank, which is a charity I really like. The LA Regional Food Bank gives out food to a lot of people in LA County. And I said, like, all right, I'm going to try to raise money for LA Regional Food Bank. Um, the, and I'll match donations up to, I can't remember what it was some $25,000 or something. And it, and like very quickly, uh, donations started pouring in. And then like a true moron, I said, if we raise $50,000 by the end of the day, uh, I will shave my head. And that, um, and it was a joke, but like that caused donations to really pour in.
嘿，当时我就想，好吧，这家伙知道我演过莫斯，而且，你知道的，当人们认出我时他会说出来的。我还记得，在大流行刚爆发的时候，我为洛杉矶地区食品银行发起了一场募捐，这是一个我非常喜欢的慈善机构。洛杉矶地区食品银行向洛杉矶县的许多人发放食物。我说，好吧，我要为洛杉矶地区食品银行筹集资金。而且，我会匹配捐款，最高可达，我不记得具体是多少了，比如25,000美元左右。结果，非常快，捐款就如潮水般涌来。然后像个真正的傻瓜一样，我说，如果在今天结束前我们能筹集到50,000美元，我就把头发剃光。那个，这其实是个玩笑，但却让捐款真正如雪片般飞来。
And to the point where like, it was like within an hour, we were at like $50,000. And so then I was like, Oh, I see, I see the game. The game is humiliation, right? Like if I just, if I offer humiliation, like we'll raise more money. So then I put it up as a poll and said, would you rather have me shave my head or grow the mosebeard and grow the mosebeard one in a landslide. So I had, so over the, in the early, in like May, May, June, July of 2020, I spent like, again, like three months growing the beard out and then shave my mustache. So I just had the beard and neck beard. And around that time I got recognized, even with masks, I got recognized like every, everywhere I went. Like that was a big, that was like a big mose moment. Cause it was right when the pandemic hit, everybody
以至于在短短一个小时内，我们就筹到了大约50,000美元。然后我想，哦，我明白了，我懂这个游戏了。这个游戏就是羞辱，对吧？如果我主动接受羞辱，我们就能筹集到更多资金。于是我发起了一个投票，问大家：你们是希望我把头发剃光，还是留莫斯的胡子？结果留莫斯的胡子以压倒性优势获胜。所以，在2020年的5月、6月、7月初这段时间里，我又花了大约三个月的时间把胡子留长，然后把小胡子剃掉。所以我只留着下巴和脖子上的胡子。那段时间我走在路上总是被认出来，哪怕戴着口罩，我走到哪里都被认出来。那真是一个“莫斯高光时刻”。因为那正值大流行爆发之际，每个人。
was streaming the show, like the popularity of the show really surged. And then also I was walking around with the beers. So that was a, there was, that was a real high, high frequency mose sighting, I would say. Oh my gosh. Okay. Okay. We've, we've talked a lot about the crazy things you had to do as mose that were sort of torturous. Was there any moment being mose that you had fun? Was there a scene? Was there one moment that you really enjoyed? It was always fun. Like it, like even when I was being tortured, it was always fun. Cause I, I really like, I revere actors in a, in a very sort of, um, childlike way. I, I, I don't, I fundamentally don't understand how actors do what you do. Uh, I, I find it to be the most difficult of all of the performing arts by far.
都在刷这部剧，这部剧的热度真的暴涨。而且当时我还留着那样的胡子。所以那一段时间，莫斯被认出的频率可以说是非常之高。天哪。好吧。好吧。我们聊了很多你不得不扮演莫斯时那些疯狂的事情，这些事情简直就像折磨一样。扮演莫斯的经历中，有哪一刻是你觉得有趣的吗？有没有哪场戏，或者哪一个瞬间是你真正享受的？其实一直都挺有趣的。就像，哪怕是在被折磨的时候，也总是很有趣。因为我，我真的很崇拜演员，用一种非常……可以说是“孩子气”的方式。我，我根本不理解演员是怎么做到你们那种表演的。我发现这是所有表演艺术中最难的一种，没有之一。
It's so much harder than writing. I think it's harder than directing. And I, I really, um, that was really hammered home to me, even when I was doing this ridiculous sight gag, and had to say a few words here and there. I was always like, God, I, I'm so much worse at this than I am in my head. Uh, which is why I'm a writer. Cause it's like what a writer is, right? I know, I know what it should be. I just don't know how to actually do it myself. So I, there were times when, for example, do you remember the episode where, um, of course you do the episode where, where Jim and Pam are excited because Shrewd Farms has become a B and B and they go and check in. It's the one where I run along the side of the car, like a dog at the beginning, right?
比写作难多了。我觉得它比导演还要难。而且我真的，这一点深深地印在了我的脑海里，哪怕是在做这种荒谬的视觉笑话、偶尔还得说几句台词的时候。我总是想，天哪，我的表现比我脑子里的想象差远了。这也是为什么我只能当个编剧。因为编剧就是这样，对吧？我知道它应该是什么样子的。我只是不知道该怎么由自己亲自把它演出来。所以，有时候，比如说，你还记得那一集吗，嗯，你当然记得那一集，吉姆和潘很兴奋，因为施鲁特农场变成了一家民宿，他们去办理入住。就是我在开头像狗一样在车旁边奔跑的那一集，对吧？
Yes. I want to mention quickly, Mike, for anybody, um, John Krasinski was not driving slow. I was, I was in the car and I, I remember that it was a hundred degrees that day because that's the day that John thought it would be really funny to prank me and put the car heater seat on, uh, because we weren't allowed to have the air conditioner for sound. And I was like, so hot, but then you were running next to the car. So I thought, well, I can't complain about being hot because I mean, look at Mike out there, like running his heart is, and John was like going fast. I mean, I, I don't know how you did it. I don't know how you did that. That was the hardest, that was the hardest acting I've ever done. And all I was doing
是的。我想简单提一下，迈克，对任何人来说，约翰·卡拉辛斯基当时开得可不慢。当时我在车里，我记得那天温度高达一百华氏度，因为那天约翰觉得捉弄我一定很有趣，他把汽车座椅加热打开了，因为为了收音，我们不能开空调。我当时热得要命，但你又在车旁边跑。所以我想，好吧，我不能抱怨太热，因为你看迈克在外面，跑得那么卖力。而且约翰开得很快。我是说，我不知道你是怎么做到的。我不知道你是怎么做到的。那是我演过最难的一场戏。而我当时做的事情。
is running because I was in those wool clothes and I was wearing those work boots and John was driving like 15 to 20 miles an hour on that dirt road and I had to keep up. And I, but also I had to run up to the window, disappear behind the car and then run fast to catch up to the other side of the window. Exactly. And also you weren't allowed to use your arms. Your arms were like, so there was like a lack of momentum that you could create because you were only using your bottom half. I want to read to you what Dunderpedia, the fan website, how they explain Moe's running. They say, Moe's proceeds to run away in his usual running with his arms swinging no higher than his waist style. I don't know where that came from. I like one of the early, one of the early Moe's
只是在奔跑，因为我穿着那些羊毛衣服，穿着那些工作靴，约翰在那条土路上以每小时15到20英里的速度开着车，我必须跟上。而且我还得跑到车窗旁，消失在车后，然后拼命快跑以赶上车窗的另一侧。没错。而且你还不被允许摆动双臂。你的手臂就像是，你没法产生惯性，因为你只能靠下半身在跑。我想读一下Dunderpedia（粉丝网站）是怎么解释莫斯奔跑的。他们说：“莫斯的标志性跑姿是向前奔跑，手臂摆动的高度绝不超过腰部。”我不知道这句是从哪儿来的。我觉得在早期莫斯的某一次。
appearances, it was like, you know, Moe's runs into the, I think it was in the, in the initiation, like Moe's runs into the room. And I don't know why, but I just did that really awkward run. That's not how I run when I'm running. I hope not. I just did that for some reason and then it just became the thing that I, that Moe's does. But what Jenna's saying is true though, because after I ran and caught up to the car, I then had to run past the car. I just speed past it and run like a hundred yards all the way over to where the farmhouse was. And I knew I wasn't on camera anymore because obviously the camera's, what's interesting is not, is not, excuse me, what's interesting is not Moe's running anymore. What's interesting is Jim and Pam reacting to
出场中，好像是在，我记得是在《入职培训》里，莫斯跑进房间。我不知道为什么，我当时就做了那个非常笨拙的奔跑动作。我平时跑步可不是这样的。希望不是。我当时不知怎么就那样跑了，然后这动作就成了莫斯的标志。不过詹娜说的是真的，因为当我跑着赶上车之后，我还得超过去。我得从车旁飞奔而过，一路狂奔大约一百码，直奔农舍。我知道自己已经不在镜头里了，因为很显然，摄像机的焦点，有趣的地方，不再是——对不起，有趣的地方不再是莫斯在奔跑。有趣的是吉姆和潘的反应。
this weird dog person that just ran alongside their car, but they made me run all the way, like a hundred yards every single time. And we did like 11 takes of that. And I, I've never been more sore in my life than I was the day after that because I didn't know that I was going to have to run a hundred, I was going to run a dozen hundred yard sprints. You were like an Olympic contender. You like outran a car. Yeah. It was the, it's the most athletic I've ever been. I would say, it's the most, the highest level of athletic achievement of my life. Well, we have it on camera. It's for all time. Forever, forever documented. There's proof. There's proof that I used to be a good runner. But I'm sorry because you were going to say something about that episode that you
看到这个刚刚在他们车旁飞奔而过的奇怪“狗人”，但他们每次都让我跑完全程，大约一百码。我们为了那个镜头拍了11条。那是我这辈子肌肉最酸痛的一次，因为我根本不知道我得跑一百码，我得连续冲刺十几次一百码。你就像个奥运会选手。你甚至跑赢了一辆车。对。那是我这辈子运动细胞最发达的时候。可以说，那是我一生中运动成就的巅峰。好吧，我们有录像为证。那是永久记录下来的。永远，永远被记录下来了。有证据。有证据证明我曾经是个跑步健将。不过对不起，因为你刚才正要说关于那一集的一些。
enjoyed. So there was a scene that I don't even know if it made it into the episode. I don't think it did, but there was a scene where Jim and Pam, in that episode at night Pam hears Dwight kind of moaning and said, because Angela has broken up with him, I think. And, and then in the morning Dwight's gone. And the, in Jim and Pam come down and are, are being, Moses serving them breakfast. Bacon, tons of bacon. Nothing but bacon. And there was, it was actually, it was the closest I ever came to having a scene because I, there were like, it was like a page of dialogue where I was serving you and you were at, you were saying like, I think Jenna, you say like, Moses, do you know where Dwight is? Or do you know where is she? Is he sad about Angela or
让你觉得享受的事情。所以有这样一场戏，我甚至不知道它最后有没有被剪进正片里。我觉得没有，但有一场戏是吉姆和潘在那个晚上的那集里，潘听到德怀特在呻吟，说是因为安吉拉和他分手了，我想是这样。然后到了早晨，德怀特不见了。吉姆和潘下楼来，莫斯在为他们端早餐。培根，超级多的培根。全是培根。其实，那是离我拥有一场真正的对手戏最近的一次，因为当时有一页纸的台词，我要端着食物服务你们，而你们坐在那儿，詹娜，你当时好像说：“莫斯，你知道德怀特在哪儿吗？你知道他在哪儿吗？他是在为安吉拉难过吗？
something? And we actually had an exchange where I like had to memorize lines and like, know what my cues were. And I remember thinking like, I'm not, this isn't, what I'm doing is not, per se, good. But I'm enjoying the process of learning what it's like to be an actor and to actually try to like, be like, be aware of the camera, be, be, be present in the scene, like, listen to what you're saying and respond with the lines that were written for me. And it was weirdly kind of thrilling. And I was like, this is never going to make it in. Like I, I had worked at the show long enough to know that we didn't have time for this weird, dumb, Moses, Jim, Pam scene. But, but I really did have fun doing it because it felt like,
还是别的什么？”我们俩确实有一段对手戏，我得背台词，还得知道什么时候该接话。我记得当时心想，我演得其实并不好，这种表演本身并不出色。但我很享受去学习如何成为一名演员的过程，去努力做到关注镜头，专注于场景，倾听你们在说什么，并用为我写好的台词做出回应。这种感觉有种奇怪的刺激感。当时我想，这绝对会被剪掉。因为我在剧组待的时间够久了，我知道我们根本没有时间去拍这个奇怪、愚蠢的莫斯、吉姆和潘的场景。但是，我拍的时候真的很开心，因为我觉得，
I think it gave me a greater appreciation just for like, what, how hard it is to do that, how hard it is to just be in a scene, have lines that you have to have memorized and know how to say them properly. And in an interesting way, while there are cameras on you, while there's people in the room, it's just a very difficult skill. I think that the, the world of television and movies would be better if every writer were forced to act sometimes. And if every actor were forced to direct, and if every director were forced to write, like if we all switched positions every once in a while, just to remind ourselves like the other skills that are involved in making TV art, each of them is so hard. It's so specific and so hard. So I really did like
这让我更加感激——仅仅是去体会要做好这件事有多难，要如何融入场景、记住台词并正确地把它们说出来有多难。而且有趣的是，当镜头对着你、房间里站着人的时候，这真的是一项非常困难的技能。我觉得，如果能让每个编剧偶尔都去客串演戏，让每个演员都去尝试当导演，让每个导演都去写剧本——如果我们每隔一段时间就能互换角色，来提醒自己制作电视艺术所涉及的其他技能是多么不易，那么电视和电影世界将会变得更好。每一种技能都如此艰难，如此独特而又艰难。所以我真的很喜欢。
that. I liked, I liked acting in those scenes just as a way to like remind me of how difficult a skill it is. Now I have a question. Yeah. Because of your experience with Mose and knowing everything that would go into some of the physical comedy bits that you were asked to do, as a writer, does it ever get in your head when you come up with a really great gag? Do you think to yourself, oh no, I'm going to have to put this actor through this horrible thing? And like, does it ever like affect your writing? It really does. And, and I have found myself talking to actors a lot and saying like, we have this idea for this silly thing. Are you cool with this? They always say yes. Like actors are incredibly adaptable people by and large. They're always happy
我喜欢在那些场景里演戏，这刚好提醒了我这是一项多么困难的技能。现在我有个问题。嗯。基于你扮演莫斯的经验，以及你深知你被要求完成的一些肢体喜剧片段需要付出多少努力，作为一个编剧，当你想到一个非常精彩的喜剧梗时，你会不会心头一紧？你会不会对自己说：“哦不，我得让这个演员经历这么可怕的事？”这会影响你的创作吗？确实会的。我发现自己经常跟演员沟通，说：“我们想了这个滑稽的点子，你觉得行吗？”他们总是说好。演员通常都是适应能力极强的人。他们总是很乐意。
to, or in my experience, I've been always happy to say like, oh yeah, that sounds fun. The one, one time I didn't do this and I wish I had, although it was fine. Nothing bad happened. But we wrote it. There was a scene in the show, The Good Place, that I created where William Jackson Harper played a character who was sort of a, he was a, he's sort of a tortured soul. He wants to be sort of morally perfect. And he believes that such a thing is possible. And there's an episode where he's sort of going through a, an existential crisis. And he's just sort of walking around lost in a daze. And he like, he goes into, he's like walking around and some sprinklers go off and they just soak him and he just kind of stands there and just gets soaked by the sprinklers.
或者根据我的经验，他们总是很乐意说：“哦，听起来挺有意思的。”有一次我没有这么做，虽然最后没事，也没有发生任何不坏的事，但我真希望我当时问了。我们写过这样的剧情。在我创作的剧集《善地》里有一场戏，威廉·杰克逊·帕尔默（William Jackson Harper）扮演一个角色，他有点像是一个饱受折磨的灵魂。他希望自己在道德上近乎完美，并且他相信这是有可能做到的。有一集他正在经历一场存在主义危机，他在那里迷茫地四处游荡。然后他走进，他到处走的时候碰上了洒水喷头，水把他的衣服全淋湿了，他就那么站在那里，任由喷头的水冲刷着自己。
And then he just kind of like takes his shirt off and just kind of keeps walking. And then you cut to him and he's in a grocery store shopping shirtless. And then, excuse me. And then like a woman comes over and is like, sir, you have to wear a shirt in here. And he just grabs like a shirt off a rack and just puts it on and smiles and keeps walking. And it turns out that William Jackson Harper is like cut. Like he's, he's like a very like physically fit person, which I did not know. Like that, I had never seen him with his shirt off before he shot that scene. But him taking his shirt off caused the internet to like explode because it was like, oh my God, the like, the dorky philosophy professor guy is also jacked. And, and I mean, it was, it was only good for him.
然后他脱掉衬衫，继续往前走。镜头一切，他光着膀子在杂货店里购物。然后，不好意思。接着有个女人走过来对他说：“先生，您在这里必须穿上衣服。”他顺手从货架上抓了一件衬衫穿上，微笑着继续往前走。结果威廉·杰克逊·帕尔默其实很有肌肉。他是那种身材非常健美的人，而我之前并不知道。在此之前我从没见过他赤膊上身的样子。但他在剧中脱掉衬衫这件事引发了互联网的狂欢，因为大家都在想：“哦天哪，这个书呆子气十足的哲学教授竟然也这么有肌肉。”而且，这对他来说只有好处。
Like I, it was like that everybody was happy with the result. But I was like, oh my God, I never asked him if it was okay that I wrote this thing where he takes his shirt off. Like I should, I should ask actors that more. Like I should say, are you okay with this? And I think if there were, it's a, it's a gendered thing in a way it shouldn't be, right? Like if it obviously if there had, if it had been a woman, I would never in a billion years have written any scene where a woman disrobes in any way without clearing it with her first. There would have been a million discussions and meetings and whatever. And it didn't occur to me that a man might also be uncomfortable with that. And so I remember thinking like, I'm so happy that it was okay, that he was okay with it,
就像，所有人都对这个结果很满意。但当时我想：“哦天哪，我从来没问过他，我写了这么一场让他脱衣服的戏，他是不是觉得OK。”我觉得我以后应该多问问演员这种事。我应该问：“你觉得这样可以吗？”而且我觉得，这其实涉及性别问题，本不该这样的。比如说，很显然，如果换作是一个女性，我绝不可能在没有事先跟她沟通的情况下，写出任何让女性以某种方式脱衣服的戏。那肯定得经过无数次的讨论、会议什么的。但当时我确实没想到，男性其实也会对此感到不自在。所以当时我想，幸好结果没事，他并不介意。
that whatever. But I also, again, like in this weirdly comes from playing Moe's and all the ridiculous I had to pick up cow patties and throw to the brain Wilson and do all sorts of like humiliating things. No one ever asked me if I was okay with any of it. And, and it, it, I do think that it's those conversations should happen more often, even when you don't think there will be any problem with this. I think there should be generally more communication between writers and directors and actors to just say like, Hey, just want to make sure you're cool with this. If you're not, it's totally okay, we can write something else. So anyway, I don't know if that answers your question or not. But well, it's really interesting because as an actor, I feel like this
不管怎样。但话说回来，这也是因为扮演莫斯以及那些不得不捡牛粪扔给布莱恩·威尔逊、做各种各样羞辱性事情的经历。从来没有人问过我，对其中的任何事情我是否觉得OK。而且，我觉得这类沟通应该更频繁地发生，哪怕你觉得这不会带来任何问题。我认为编剧、导演和演员之间应该有更多的交流，直接说：“嘿，只是想确认一下你能不能接受这个。如果你觉得不行完全没问题，我们可以改写别的。”所以，不管怎样，我不知道这算不算回答了你的问题。不过，这真的很有趣，因为作为演员，我觉得这种情况。
comes up a lot in television, because you agree to play a character, but you don't know what is going to be written about your character beyond the pilot episode. Yeah. And so there could be years and years and years of stories, and they are a surprise to the actor every week. And so with a movie, well, I can see the movie script. If there's like three weird sex scenes or like a weird scene that makes me uncomfortable, I can just say, Oh, I, this isn't the part for me. Right. Right. The whole story. Yeah, I know everything that's being asked of me when I accept that movie role. But when you accept a television role, you don't know what's going to be asked of you. And I've always thought that that communication, you know, this, this came up on our show later
在电视剧里经常发生，因为你同意扮演一个角色，但除了试播集之外，你根本不知道之后会给你的角色写出什么样的故事。对。所以可能会有整整好几年、好几年的故事走向，而这些对演员来说每周都是惊喜。拍电影就不一样，我可以看电影剧本。如果有三场奇怪的床戏或者让我感到不舒服的奇怪场景，我可以直接说：“哦，这个角色不适合我。”没错，没错。整个故事都在那儿。对，当我接受那个电影角色时，我对所有要求我做的事情都一清二楚。但当你接受一个电视剧角色时，你根本不知道接下来会面临什么。我一直觉得这种沟通方式——
when they came up with the really funny idea that Pam would have a male lactation consultant who would be massaging her breasts in front of Jim, and that Pam and the lactation consultant would find this very clinical and that Jim was trying to also find it clinical trying to be cool. Yeah. But was also like, this handsome man is massaging my wife's breasts right now. And, and I remember they came up to me and said, we think this is really funny. But we imagine that it would be weird for you to have a total stranger that you met that day, come and handle your breasts. And the joke only works if they're actually touching your breasts. So what if your fiance Lee played the role and then it's someone who's already massaging your breasts,
这后来在我们的剧里也出现过，当时他们想出了一个非常搞笑的点子：潘有一个男泌乳顾问，要在吉姆面前帮她按摩乳房，而且潘和这位泌乳顾问都觉得这非常医疗化、非常专业，吉姆也试图表现得很专业、很酷。但心里同时又在想：“这个帅哥现在正在帮我老婆按摩乳房呢。”我记得他们来找我说：“我们觉得这个点子超级好笑。但我们猜，对于你来说，让一个你当天刚认识的陌生人来接触你的胸部，可能会觉得怪怪的。而且这个笑话只有在他们真的碰到你胸部时才成立。所以，不如让你的未婚夫李（Lee）来演这个角色，这样本来就是他在帮你按摩。
massaging your breasts. And I was like, well, he does massage them. So that is true. And so it was great. So then it was just weird for John. Yeah, then it was just weird for everyone else. Because we were super comfortable. Well, I think that's that's first of all good for them for obviously bringing that up. But also like that, there is an enormous leap of faith that you're taking as an actor when you start onto a TV show, right? You're really like you're using a very small amount of data, which is usually like a pilot script, and maybe a meeting with the show creator or the show runner, and you're extrapolating over potentially 10 years and 200 episodes of like, am I putting my faith and trust in this person? And is it going to be rewarded?
按摩你的乳房。”当时我就想，嗯，他确实经常按摩。所以这倒不假。太棒了。所以这样一来，只有约翰觉得尴尬了。对，那就只是对其他人来说比较尴尬了。因为我们之间超级自然。嗯，我觉得——首先，他们能主动提出来这点真的很棒。但同时，当你开始出演一部电视剧时，作为演员，你其实是做出了一个巨大的信仰之跃，对吧？你仅仅根据极少的信息——通常是一个试播集剧本，或许再加上与剧集主创或制片人的几次会面——就在推测长达10年、200集的未来：我真的能把信仰和信任寄托在这个人身上吗？这种信任会得到回报吗？
Or are there going to be constant battles and fights about creative directions and and things that they asked me to do that? And the and that this is part of why being an actor, I think, is so difficult. This you only your only advocate is yourself. Like you don't have, you know, you maybe have an agent or a manager who can have your back in those moments. But it's like this idea of like the quote, difficult actor and quote, like, I think that is a a horrible misnomer that has come from now 80 years of actors being getting a new script every week and not having any idea what's in it. And those ideas coming from people who maybe haven't run a bunch of things by them. And just being like, Oh, man, now I got to do this this week. And
还是说会迎来没完没了的关于创作方向的争吵、打斗，以及他们要求我去做一些我不愿意做的事？这也是为什么我觉得当演员这么难的一部分原因。你唯一的拥护者只有你自己。你没有——也许你有个经纪人或经理能在关键时刻为你撑腰。但诸如“难搞的演员”这种说法，我觉得这真是一个糟糕的误称。这种说法源于过去80年来，演员每周都会拿到一份新剧本，而对里面的内容一无所知。这些点子来自于那些可能并没有跟他们充分沟通的人，他们只会说：“哦，天哪，我这周又得演这个了。”而且。
the range of how it can make an actor feel uncomfortable is enormous. It can be anything from like, a strange man has to massage parts of your body that you might not want that person to massage all the way to just creative decisions about the character, the choices the character makes things that the character does that you don't agree with. Like, it's just really hard. It's a it's a very difficult thing. And the chance for it to go sideways is enormous. So the more communication there is between writers and actors, the better to bring this full circle. That's another thing that I remember thinking I could attribute to SNL a little bit with Greg, because Greg worked there. At SNL, like everybody does everything, writers act and actors write
它让演员感到不舒服的程度是极其巨大的。小到可能是一个陌生的男人不得不按摩你身体某些你不想让他按摩的部位，大到仅仅是对角色本身的创作决策、角色的选择、角色做出的你并不认同的事情。总之这真的太难了。这是一件非常困难的事，而且事情搞砸的可能性极大。因此，编剧和演员之间的沟通越多越好。把话题绕回来，我记得这也是我可以归功于周六夜生活秀（SNL）和格雷格的一点，因为格雷格在那里工作过。在SNL，每个人什么都干，编剧去演戏，演员去写剧本。
and it's very like community theater kind of feeling. And there's no division between actors and writers really at all, like it's all one big hodgepodge. And that was Greg's whole theory was like, let's let's break down these artificial barriers between the writers and the actors. That's why he wanted Mindy and BJ and Paul to act in the show. It's why he want it's why he gave the this season two finale where Jim and Pam where Jim tells Pam that he likes or is in love with her and that they kiss for the first time. Steve wrote that he gave that to Steve like that's traditionally the kind of thing that like he would write or like the co EP trusted writer would write that script. But Greg saw the big picture and he understood fundamentally that the more there
那种感觉非常像社区剧院。编剧和演员之间其实没有什么界限，一切都是一个大杂烩。而这正是格雷格的整体理论：让我们打破编剧和演员之间这些虚假的人为壁垒。这也是为什么他想让明迪、B.J.和保罗在剧中演戏。这也是为什么他，为什么在第二季大结局中，当吉姆告诉潘他喜欢她或爱上了她、他们第一次接吻时，是由史蒂夫写的这个剧本。他把这个交给了史蒂夫——传统上，这种情节应该由他自己写，或者由备受信任的联合执行制片人来写。但格雷格看到了大局，他从根本上理解，越是。
was that we he broke down the divisions between writers and actors the healthier the organism of the show would be and he was totally right. So true. I mean, Jenna and I have talked about that a lot on this podcast, other shows that we have done since the office. I did a guest star on a show and the writer's room was in New York and we filmed in LA. And I thought, wow, they never meet the writers, they never interact with them at all. And it's just been such an interesting and wonderful perspective to look back at how fortunate we were to have that sort of creative collaboration as our biggest job in our life. I've bounced up to writers on sets at other jobs. Thinking that the way we had it on the office was normal and they seem terrified to speak to me.
打破编剧和演员之间的界限，剧集这个有机体就会越健康。他完全是对的。太真实了。我是说，我和詹娜在这档播客里，以及在我们离开《办公室》之后拍的其他剧集里，经常谈到这一点。我曾在一部剧里客串，当时编剧室在纽约，我们在洛杉矶拍摄。当时我想，哇，他们永远见不到编剧，跟编剧没有任何互动。回过头来看，我们能把这种创意合作作为人生中最大的一份工作，是多么的幸运，这种视角是如此有趣和美好。我在其他剧组里也试过直接去找编剧。以为我们在《办公室》里的那种模式是正常的，结果他们看起来好像很害怕跟我说话。
They are terrified that I am talking to them. They are afraid to say anything. I'll be like, hey, what's up? What do you think next week? What do you think is going to be like, how's this story going to play out? And they're like, I don't want to speak to you. The first time I did a multi-cam after the office because I'd never done a multi-cam, all the writers were like huddled in a corner. You know, like we're filming. It's like filming a one act play and they're all in the corner because I knew this joke wasn't working and I had like a few ideas. So I went up to the huddle and I was like, hey guys, I got like a two or three pitches and they were like, what? It was like a record scratch. Yeah, I know. And again, Greg's ethos was Greg's ethos in a nutshell is best idea wins and he doesn't
他们害怕我在跟他们说话。他们害怕说任何话。我会说：“嘿，最近怎么样？你觉得下周剧情会怎样？你觉得这个故事会怎么发展？”而他们的反应是：“我不想跟你说话。”我离开《办公室》后第一次拍多机位情景喜剧时，因为我从没拍过多机位，所有的编剧都缩在角落里。你知道的，就像我们在拍一幕剧，他们全躲在角落里，因为我知道那个笑话效果不好，我有一些想法。于是我走向那个小团体，说道：“嘿伙计们，我有两三个点子。”结果他们的反应是：“什么？”简直像唱片跳针一样。对，我懂。再说一次，格雷格的精神核心一言以蔽之就是：最好的点子胜出。他才不。
care whether the best idea comes from a writer, an actor, a director, an accountant, a random person on the street who happens to walk by at the right moment and has a good pitch. It was just, why would we not take the best idea? And so that fostered that sense of like, everybody give us all your ideas. Like let's put all of the ideas into a pot and pick the best one. And that is very frequently sadly not how it works on other shows. And it's a shame because, you know, there were times when we would be battling about something in the edit bay about an episode and that he would have two alts and he would say, which one do you like? And all of the writers would choose version A and he would go like, and then he would call in like the accounting department. Yeah.
在乎最好的点子是来自编剧、演员、导演、会计，还是某个路过时恰好有好点子的路人。为什么我们不采用最好的点子呢？这种氛围培养了一种意识：每个人都把你们的点子拿出来！把所有的点子放进一个池子里，然后挑出最好的那个。但不幸的是，在其他剧组里，情况往往不是这样的，这真的很遗憾。你知道，有时候我们在剪辑室里为了一集的某个问题争论不休，当时他有两个备选方案，他会问：“你喜欢哪一个？”所有的编剧都会选A版本，然后他会说——接着他会把会计部门的人叫进来。对。
And he'd be like, which one do you like? The real accountant. The actual accountant. Yeah. Yeah. Not you and Oscar. Yeah, not me and Brian and Oscar. And he would go, which one do you like? And they would say, we like B. And he's like, yeah, I think B is better. And it drove us crazy sometimes. But he was like, you're not the audience. You're professional comedy writers. Like, of course, you're going to like this weird offbeat thing that we did. You know what the best example of this is? So Jim's proposal to Pam at the at the gas station, right? So three versions, I don't know if you remember this, Jenna, we had three versions. One of them was the car pulls over, the camera is across the street and is shooting super long lens. And all you hear is traffic
然后问：“你们喜欢哪一个？”真正的会计。真正的会计。对，对。不是你和奥斯卡。对，不是我和布莱恩还有奥斯卡。他会问：“你们喜欢哪个？”他们会回答：“我们喜欢B。”然后他就会说：“对，我觉得B更好。”这有时把我们气得够呛。但他会说：“你们不是观众。你们是专业的喜剧编剧。所以，你们当然会喜欢我们拍的这种奇怪、非主流的东西。”你知道这最好的例子是什么吗？吉姆在加油站向潘求婚的那场戏。当时有三个版本——詹娜，我不知道你还记不记得，我们拍了三个版本。其中一个版本是车停在路边，摄像机在街对面，用超长焦镜头拍摄。你听到的只有交通。
whizzing by in the foreground. And you can't hear they're not miked in this in this version. The sound was off. So you saw Jim walk up and you saw Pam and the ha ha. And then all of a sudden they're talking, you don't know what they're saying. Jim gets down on one knee, Pam reacts. And they and then they hug and they kiss and it's over. And second version was or the final version was like very traditionally shot, like you were right with them in the gas station, sort of looking in a classic TV coverage. And you could still hear traffic whizzing by in the background, but you couldn't really see it. And the cameras are right up close. And then there was a sort of intermediate version where you were a little bit further away, but you could hear
车流在前景中呼啸而过的声音。在这个版本里他们没有戴麦克风。声音是关闭的。所以你看到吉姆走过去，看到潘和他们的互动。然后突然间他们在说话，你根本听不清他们在说什么。吉姆单膝跪地，潘做出反应。然后他们拥抱、亲吻，就结束了。第二个版本，或者说最终版本，拍摄手法非常传统，就像你和他们在加油站里近距离面对面一样，采用的是经典的电视剧镜头调度。你依然能听到背景中汽车呼啸而过的声音，但你看不到车。摄像机离得非常近。然后还有一个折中版本，就是你离得稍微远一点，但你能听清。
what they were saying. And he screened all three of them. And the the one that was where the camera was super far away. And you couldn't hear a word gave me like the greatest goose bump feeling of my life. Like I was like, that's so beautiful. It's so perfect for the show. It reminded me of the scene in the British office where Tim takes off his mic and goes in and talks to Don. That was the sort of model of it where and you don't hear what they're saying. And then he comes back out and grabs the mic and says, she said no, by the way, and and it's terrible and sad. And I was like, well, that's that's a home run. That's like the most beautiful. It's so perfect. It's the most beautiful thing ever. And he was like, Yeah, we're not using that version. That was like, why? And
他们在说什么。他把这三个版本都拿去试映了。那个摄像机离得超级远、一个字也听不见的版本，给了我一生中最大的一起鸡皮疙瘩的感觉。当时我想：太美了。这太契合这部剧了。它让我想起了英国版《办公室》里蒂姆摘下麦克风走进去跟唐说话的那场戏。那就是它的原型，你听不到他们在说什么。然后他走出来，抓起麦克风说：“顺便说一句，她拒绝了。”那种感觉太糟糕、太伤感了。当时我想：这绝对是个全垒打。太完美了。这是史上最美的画面。而他却说：“对，我们不用那个版本。”我当时就问：“为什么？”
he was like, because this is a moment that fans of the show have been waiting for for five, six years, whatever it was. And it's not it's just fundamentally not fair to deny them the ability to hear Jim say, will you marry me? It's just mean it's like it and and this might be the most sort of like, beautiful, artistic, you know, like highfalutin version. But if if what what are we doing if we're denying fans the ability to hear Jim say, will you marry me and hear Pam say, yes, that's just cruel. And I always fought him on all of those decisions. And he was always right. It's just like at the end of the day, I was like, of course, of course, you need to hear will you marry me? Yes, like, oh, that that's such a foundational moment in the history of the show.
他当时就说，因为这是剧迷们等了五年、六年甚至更久的一个时刻。剥夺他们听到吉姆说“你愿意嫁给我吗”的权利，从根本上说是不公平的。这太刻薄了，就像……这或许是最完美、最艺术、也最阳春白雪的版本。但如果我们剥夺了剧迷们听到吉姆说“你愿意嫁给我”以及听到帕姆说“我愿意”的权利，那我们在干什么？这太残忍了。我总是为所有这些决定跟他争论。而他总是对的。到了最后我就觉得，当然，当然，你必须得听到“你愿意嫁给我吗？我愿意”，哦，这真是剧史上至关重要的一个时刻。
And so he had that he had that thing of like, let's develop and explore every possible idea. Let's walk down every path. Let's pull every name out of the hat. And at the end of the day, we will choose the one that is the best for the show, not the one that's loved the most by the people who work on the show or the writers who write things or any anything else, just what is what is the best thing for the show. And that's why the show over the course of its decade long run had such an integrity to it, I think it's because it was always the decisions were always made in terms of what's best for the show, not not what a bunch of like jaded writers thought would be the coolest thing or something like that. Do you want to ask Mike about the Christmas lights?
所以他一直坚持这种理念：让我们去构思和探讨每一种可能的想法。让我们走遍每一条路。让我们从帽子里掏出每一个名字。到了最后，我们要选出对这部剧最好的那个，而不是剧组人员或编剧们最喜欢的那个，也不是其他什么，只选对这部剧最好的那个。这就是为什么这部剧在长达十年的播出期间能保持这样的一致性，我认为正是因为它的所有决定始终都是从“什么对剧最好”出发，而不是从一群饱经沧桑的编剧觉得什么最酷之类的一直在变的角度出发。你想问迈克关于圣诞彩灯的事吗？
Oh, yeah, I do. This is such a hard pivot. But we, okay, so in the first Christmas episode, which, oh my God, I just love that episode so much, I can watch it like every year. It's almost like, you know, what do you like to watch at the holidays? Oh, that, you know, Christmas vacation, which every chase, I like to watch the very first Christmas episode Yankee swap. I have had a Yankee swap party for years inspired by that episode. I love everything about it. So there was this moment that we heard was inspired by your real life where when they put up the Christmas tree, the, the tiny, tiny Christmas lights and Angela's so mad at Phyllis, she's so pissed off. And we heard that was like actually based on something in your life where
哦，对，我想问。这话题转得太硬了。但是，好吧，在第一集的圣诞特别节目里——哦天哪，我太喜欢那一集了，我几乎每年都能看一遍。这就好像，你知道，你在节日里喜欢看什么？哦，那部，你知道的，疯狂圣诞假期，那部由切维·切斯主演的电影，我喜欢看第一集圣诞白象交换礼物。受那一集的启发，我办了好几年的白象交换礼物派对。我喜欢关于它的一切。我们听说有一个情节灵感来自你的真实生活，当时他们挂圣诞树的时候，那些小得不行的圣诞彩灯把安吉拉气坏了，她气炸了。我们听说那其实是基于你生活中的某件事，当时
there was, is that true? And were there other moments like that, like things that were in your life that made it into the show? Totally true. My first Christmas in LA, my, my then fiance, now wife JJ and I got our first tree as cohabitants. And we were so excited. We both love Christmas. We love like decorating the tree. We love everything. And we bought the tree and we took it home. We put it up and we played Christmas music. And we had bought these my in my house growing up, you always did only white lights. I don't know why that was that was like what our family preferred. And JJ had been like, I like the big colored ones. They're so like cheery and happy. And I, for some reason, won the argument. I don't know why, but I was
这是真的吗？还有其他类似的事情吗，比如你生活中的事被搬进了剧里？完全是真的。我在洛杉矶过的第一个圣诞节，我当时的未婚妻、现在的妻子JJ和我，作为同居伴侣买回了我们的第一棵树。我们太兴奋了。我们俩都喜欢圣诞节。我们喜欢装饰树。我们喜欢一切。我们买了树，把它带回家。我们把它立起来，放起了圣诞音乐。我们还买了这些……在我长大的家里，我们总是只用白灯。我不知道为什么，那是我们家偏爱的那种。而JJ则说：“我喜欢那种大颗的彩色灯。它们看起来多么欢快开心啊。”而不知为什么，我赢了这场争论。我不知道为什么，但我当时就
like, trust me, it looks great. It looks great. And so I went and bought those little tiny white lights. And I very carefully strung them around the tree and everything. And then we, we like, we're playing Christmas music and it was like a big countdown. And I turned them on and you absolutely could not see any of them. They just say it was the saddest, the least, the least, it was the opposite of the Rockefeller center Christmas tree lighting. And, and I was immediately humiliated and my wife was just laughing at me so hard, like just what a complete failure this was. And I immediately went out and went to the drugstore and bought big, big colored lights and came home and we strung them up. And so I, but I remember that, that feeling and like that episode
像是，相信我，这看起来棒极了。看起来棒极了。于是我去买了那些小小的白灯。我非常小心地把它们串在树上，诸如此类。然后我们开始播放圣诞音乐，就像是在进行一场盛大的倒计时。我打开了它们，结果你完全看不到它们。它们简直是……那是最悲伤的、最不像样子的，简直是洛克菲勒中心圣诞树亮灯仪式的反面。然后我立刻感到羞愧难当，我妻子在一旁疯狂地笑话我，笑我这完全是个彻底的失败。我马上跑出去，去药店买了大颗的彩色灯回来，我们把它们串了上去。所以，我依然记得那种感觉，而且那一集
is so much about like expectation versus reality. And so I was like, Oh, that would be a good, like little metaphor for what's about to happen to Michael Scott when he gets the Phyllis's oven met. So I just, I put it in as like Greg was so into, and the show was so into those tiny, tiny, tiny observable moments of real life. And, and so I thought, well, that makes perfect sense. And my favorite thing about that is after they turn the lights on and Michael goes, not great. There's a quick pan to Angela who just looks angrier than she has ever looked in her entire life. I know. That episode gave me a full headache because I was just always so angry. Scowling, just scowling everybody. Yeah. I mean, there, that, so much of what happened
很大程度上讲的就是期望与现实的落差。所以我想，哦，这对于迈克·斯科特拿到菲莉丝的烤箱隔热垫时将要遭遇的事情来说，会是一个很好的小隐喻。所以我把它加了进去，因为格雷格对这种现实生活中微小、可观察的细节非常痴迷，整部剧也是如此。所以我想，这太合情合理了。而我最喜欢的一点是，在他们开灯之后，迈克说：“不太妙。”镜头迅速切到安吉拉，她的表情比她一生中任何时候都要愤怒。我知道。那一集让我头疼欲裂，因为我当时总是那么生气。怒目而视，对每个人怒目而视。是的。我是说，在那前几集里，
in those first, in that, especially in the first season and a half, you know, seasons one and two, so much of that stuff was real observation, like about people's lives, like all of the gifts in that, that I invented for the, this, this was another great writing lesson that came from that episode. So in my original version, the person who had Angela, maybe no, Oscar had Creed, who had Toby, right, right. So Toby in the original version had a talking head where he was like, I don't know a lot about Angela. I know that she's religious. So I bought her this book and the book was one of those sort of religious adjacent self-help books, you know, like sort of like leading, leading a spiritual life or something. It's one of those kind of hokey books. And Greg
特别是在第一季和第二季的前期，你知道，很多那种东西都是真实的观察，比如关于人们的生活，比如我在那集里为……这也是从那一集学到的另一个绝佳的写作经验。所以在我最初的版本里，抽到安吉拉的人——或者不对，是奥斯卡抽到克里德，克里德抽到托比，对，对。所以托比在最初的版本里有一段面对镜头的独白，他说：“我对安吉拉了解不多。我知道她信教。所以我给她买了这个书。”这本书是那种带有宗教色彩的自助书，你知道的，有点像引导过精神生活之类的。那是那种俗气的书。然后格雷格
was like, I don't think that he should give her that book because we already know that Angela has that tendency or leans in that direction. And so you're not, the audience isn't getting any new information. And I was like, all right, well, like, what could it be? And then someone, I might have been Greg, pitched that thing of a poster of babies who are dressed like adults. Yeah. And we, nobody could understand why, but it was the perfect thing. It was just, that's a perfect thing that it was like, you're learning more about Angela, right? You got a new piece of information about her character. And, but it's still very much in keeping with what we already know about her. And then that, and then that poster became like basis of like
就说，我觉得他不应该送她那本书，因为我们已经知道安吉拉有那种倾向，或者说她本来就倾向于那个方向。所以你没有向观众传递任何新信息。我就说，好吧，那还能是什么呢？然后有人——可能就是格雷格——提出了这样一个点子：一张打扮成成年人的婴儿海报。对。我们谁也无法理解为什么，但这简直是绝妙的主意。它就是那种完美的点子，让你能对安吉拉有更多了解，对不对？你得到了关于她角色的新信息。但这仍然非常符合我们对她的既有认知。然后，这张海报后来成了……
four other stories over the course. Oh yeah. It became a huge source of contention between Angela and Oscar because she hung it by her desk. And Oscar had to wear it as a, as a shirt. Yeah. Well, Angela in real life really likes animals who are dressed in costumes of other animals. I mean, it's very similar. It's very similar to liking babies dressed as adults, I think. I mean, animals dressed as any, anything really. Like if, if on Halloween you dress your dog as a hot dog, I'm going to be like, oh my gosh, your dog's a hot dog. So we have two dogs and this year they were ketchup and mustard. Oh, I love it. Oh, I would love to see a picture of that. That lights up Angela's life. It really does. So wait, animals dressed like other animals,
整整四季中另外四个故事的基础。哦，对。它成了安吉拉和奥斯卡之间巨大的矛盾根源，因为她把它挂在办公桌旁。而奥斯卡不得不把它穿在身上当衬衫。对。嗯，现实生活中的安吉拉真的很喜欢穿着其他动物服装的动物。我的意思是，这和喜欢打扮成成年人的婴儿非常相似，我想。我是说，打扮成任何东西的动物其实都一样。比如说，如果在万圣节你把你的狗打扮成热狗，我会觉得，哦天哪，你的狗是个热狗。所以我们有两只狗，今年它们一个是番茄酱一个是芥末酱。哦，我太喜欢了。哦，我很想看一张那样的照片。那能点亮安吉拉的生活。确实如此。等等，打扮成其他动物的动物，
you mean like, like a, like a dog dressed like a cow or like, oh yeah, or like a teddy bear that's, but has like a bunny hat. Yeah, I know why. Mike, thank you so much for coming on Office Ladies today. This was such a treat. We want to tell people that you wrote a book. Yes. And the book is called How to Be Perfect. It comes out on January 25th. Tell us about it. So this book came out of the show The Good Place that I created, which was about, if you haven't seen it, it's very hard to explain it in one sentence, but it's essentially a, I pitched it as a show about like what it means to be a good person. And for the show, I read a lot of ethics and philosophy by a lot of very old, boring people. And I thought, I had this thought while I was researching it, which was
你是说，就像一只打扮成奶牛的狗，或者——哦对，或者像一只戴着小兔帽的泰迪熊。对，我知道为什么。迈克，非常感谢你今天来到“办公室女士”播客。这真是一次极好的享受。我们要告诉大家你写了一本书。是的。这本书叫《如何完美》（How to Be Perfect）。它将于1月25日出版。给我们讲讲它吧。所以这本书源自我创作的剧集《善地》（The Good Place），如果你没看过的话，很难用一句话来解释它，但它基本上是……我把它推销为一部关于“做好人意味着什么”的剧。为了这部剧，我读了很多非常古老、无聊的人写的伦理学和哲学著作。我想，我在研究的时候产生了这样一个想法，那就是
that these people have such good ideas for how to be better people. Like, as all of these ethical theories in this moral philosophy is like, it's like a how-to guide for like living a good life and being a good person on earth, but they're writing a so tortured and boring that no one wants to read it. So maybe I could write a version where I sort of try to explain as best as I can what their theories are, but in a way that doesn't give you a tension headache and make you sleepy. So that's what it is. It's sort of a summary of a lot of different theories in moral philosophy. The way that the book is sort of organized is like, I pose a bunch of boring questions or mundane questions that face us every day. Like, if my friend bought an ugly shirt and says, what do you think
这些人关于如何成为更好的人有着如此美妙的想法。就像所有这些道德哲学中的伦理学理论，它就像一本如何在地球上过上好日子、做一个好人的“操作指南”，但他们的文风是如此折磨人又无聊，以至于根本没人想读。所以也许我可以写一个版本，我尽量用我能做到的最好方式去解释他们的理论，但用一种不会让你神经性头疼、昏昏欲睡的方式。所以这就是它的本质。它算是对道德哲学中各种不同理论的总结。这本书的组织方式大概是这样的：我提出了一组我们在日常生活中都会面临的无聊问题或世俗问题。比如，如果我的朋友买了一件丑陋的衬衫并问：“你觉得我的衬衫怎么样？”对她撒谎可以吗？或者你可以，或者你可以，还是你必须说实话？所以它就是这样一些在日常生活中经常出现的问题。然后我试着解释不同的道德哲学家和伦理学家会对这些问题说些什么。这就是核心构想。它将于1月发售。它现在已经开售了。你可以从你偏好的任何在线书店购买它。并且所有的收益都将捐给慈善机构。所以你买下它，就会知道通过把钱捐给慈善机构，你正在为世界做一件好事。哦，我太喜欢了。仅仅通过买这本书，我就在做一个好人。没错。就是这个主意。是的。所以你真的在为我的成功铺路。我知道。我喜欢。我也很喜欢。
of my shirt? Is it okay to lie to her? Or can you, or can you, or do you have to tell the truth? And so it's questions like that, that are just things that come up in everyday life. And then I try to explain what like different moral philosophers and ethicists would say about those questions. So that's the idea. And it's on sale January. It's on sale now. You can buy it now from any online bookstore that you prefer. And also all of the proceeds are going to charity. So you can buy it and know that you're doing something good in the world by having money go to charity. Oh, I love that. Just by buying the book, I am being a good person. That's right. That's the idea. Yeah. So you're really setting me up to succeed. I know. I like it. I like it too.
你马上就会知道，仅仅通过买这本书，你就让世界变得稍微美好了一点了。就这么简单。做一个好人就是这么简单。我太喜欢了。好吧，这是敏迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）对你的书的评价。她说：“作为一个担心深入探讨道德会毁了我有趣而又问题重重的人生的人，我曾确信这本书不适合我。天哪，我大错特错了。它如此才华横溢、妙趣横生又温情脉脉。你甚至意识不到，仅仅通过阅读它，你就在成为一个更好的人。”是的。她为这本书写封底推荐语真是太好了。她的推荐语实际上成了封面文案，我想我之前还没告诉你呢。封面推荐语。哦，封面推荐语。我在网上找到了。
You know, right away that you've made the world a slightly better place just by buying the book. It's that easy. It's that easy to be a good person. I love it. Well, this is what Mindy Kaling had to say about your book. She said, as someone who worries that a deep dive into morality will ruin my fun and problematic life, I was certain this book wouldn't be for me. Boy was I wrong. It's so brilliant and funny and warmly written. You don't realize you're becoming a better person just by reading it. Yes. It was very nice of her to blurb the book. Her blurb is actually the one that made the cover, which I don't think I've told you yet. Cover blurb. Oh, cover blurb. I found it online.
那可是高级推荐语。嗯，我太兴奋想读它了。是的。我已经订购了我的副本，安吉拉也订了两本，我们打算去拿。迈克，谢谢你，因为我——好吧，我也是你推特（Twitter）的超级粉丝。我觉得你非常非常擅长把复杂的观点或想法变得极其浅显易懂且妙趣横生。你还非常擅长剖析棒球数据。是的。我发现，如果有重大比赛，我就会去看你的推特，因为我想，哦，好吧，我知道迈克会向我解释这一切，因为我根本不知道所有的那些喧嚣到底是怎么回事。你这么说真是太客气了。我经常纳闷，到底是谁还在看我的推特，因为上面要么是荒谬晦涩的体育数据，要么就是在大喊大叫地评论某个
That's fancy blurb right there. Well, I'm so excited to read it. Yes. I have ordered my copy and Angela has two and we're going to get them. And Mike, thank you because I, well, I'm a huge fan of your Twitter as well. I feel like you're very, very good at taking complex ideas or thoughts and making them really digestible and entertaining. You're also very good at breaking down baseball statistics. Yes. I have found, I go to your Twitter if there's a big game on because I'm like, oh, well, I know that Mike is going to explain this to me because I don't know what all the hullabaloo is about. It's very kind of you to say. I often wonder who in the world is still reading my Twitter because it is either in ridiculous arcane sports data or just screaming about something that a
政客说的话。而且这两类想看这两样东西的人群的韦恩图交集一定小得可怜。所以我很高兴得知你们俩依然处于阅读我推特的韦恩图交集之中。我是。我看不懂你的体育分析。不总是能看懂，没有。但我只是觉得看着你的大脑运转非常迷人。是的。而且我们热爱数据。詹娜和我发现我们的共同点之一就是我们喜欢追踪各种数据。我们会感到非常兴奋。只要你能说出名字，我们就会在剧里追踪它。比如我变得对前台的每一株植物都着迷不已，我会记录下每周是如何出现一株新植物的。而这是我觉得棒球最迷人的地方，那里有那么多不同的统计数据。我不懂
politician said. And it's like the Venn diagram for the two groups of people that want both of those things has to be tiny. So I'm glad to know that you two are still in the Venn diagram overlap of people who read my Twitter. I am. I don't understand your sports analysis. Not always, no. But I find it just sort of fascinating to watch your brain work. Yes. And we love data. Jenna and I have discovered one of the things we have in common is we love tracking things. We get very excited. Just you name it. We track it on the show. Like I became obsessed about every plant that was at front reception and I would document how every week there was a new plant. And that's something that I find fascinating about baseball is there's so many different stats. I don't understand
它们，但当有重大比赛、大家都在讨论数据时，我会去看你的推特。是的。投球。你真的把投球给剖析透了。对。好吧，人们喜欢棒球的一部分原因以及讨厌它的一部分原因，就是你可以分析的数据量。我喜欢它，因为我和你一样，对数字和统计数据有种书呆子般的狂热。但是话说回来，当我在我的推特账号上连续发11条推文讨论某记投球到底是好球还是坏球时，我确实会想：这是写给谁看的？现在到底是谁在读这个并乐在其中？但这就是推特的乐趣所在。如果你不想知道，你永远不必知道。你只需把它发到宇宙里，谁管呢？好吧，我们有一个最后的总结性问题
them, but I will go to your Twitter when there's a big game and people are talking about stats. Yes. Pitches. You really break down the pitches. Yeah. Well, part of what some people love about baseball and what some people hate about it is the amount of data that you can analyze. I love it because I'm the same way I get nerdy about numbers and stats and stuff. But again, when I go to my Twitter account and post 11 consecutive tweets about whether a certain pitch was a ball or a strike, I do have the thought of like, who is this for? Who is reading this right now and enjoying it? But that's the joy of Twitter's. You don't ever have to know if you don't want to know. You can just send it out in the university and who cares? Well, we have one final wrap up question
要问你。我们总是会问所有上过这档节目或为这档节目工作过的人，他们有没有从片场拿走什么东西。好吧。不像你采访过的许多人，我中途离开了。对。我在前四季以及第五季初待过，然后格雷格和我开始一起开发《公园与游憩》（Parks and Recreation）。我在办公室的办公区工作。我还在，但慢慢地在第五季的过程中，我退居幕后了。所以我不知道，我想我在理智上并没有意识到我正在真正地离开。所以我并没有真正想过从片场顺走什么特别的东西，因为感觉就像是它们还在被使用。对。我们还在拍这部剧。所以我真的没有拿
for you. We always ask everyone who was on the show or worked on the show if they took anything from the set. Okay. Unlike probably many of the people that you've interviewed, I left in the middle. Right. I was around for the first four seasons and then the beginning of season five, and then Greg and I started developing parks and recreation together. I worked out of the office offices. I was still around, but slowly over the course of season five, I receded into the background. So I didn't know, I think sort of intellectually understand that I was leaving, leaving. And so I didn't really think to grab anything specific from the set because it was like they were still being used. Right. We're still making the show. So I really didn't take
任何东西。我确实有几件我非常珍视的与本剧相关的东西。其中一件是当我离开时，李·艾森伯格（Lee Eisenberg）和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基（Gene Stupnitsky）去找了道具大师菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea），拿到了制作安吉拉送给德怀特的礼物——那个德怀特摇头娃娃的人的联系方式。他们让人制作了一个迈克的摇头娃娃作为某种临别礼物。所以我还留着这个迈克的摇头娃娃。唯一的毛病是，我以前常戴……我现在每天都戴隐形眼镜，但在那个时候我经常戴眼镜，因为我们经常要工作到凌晨一点左右。我的隐形眼镜会变干，而那个迈克的摇头娃娃原本戴着真正的眼镜。在某个时候，我想是在我们搬家的时候，眼镜摔断了，
anything. I have a couple of things that I do treasure that are related to the show. One of which was when I left, Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stupnitzky went to Phil Shea, property master Phil Shea, and got his contact for who made the Dwight bobblehead that Angela had given to Dwight as a present. And they had a Mike bobblehead made as like, it was sort of like a parting gift. And so I still have the Mike bobblehead. The only problem is I used to wear, I wear contacts now every day, but back then I wore glasses pretty often because we would often work until like, you know, one in the morning. And my contacts would dry out and the bobble, the Mike bobblehead had had actual glasses on. And at some point, I think when we moved, the glasses broke off,
这真是一件令人沮丧的事。我经常考虑试着修复它们。所以我还没有把它们安回去。所以我有一个迈克的摇头娃娃，而且我确实在某个地方——甚至我都不知道在哪里——有这样一个时刻：每个人都意识到“世界上最棒的老板”马克杯会成为这部剧播出期间的一个重要道具。菲尔订了大约24个，以防它们摔碎或者我们需要更多之类的。我问他能不能给我一个，他给了我一个。所以我有一个“世界上最棒的老板”马克杯，不是那种被使用过的。它不是著名的那个。它不是片头字幕里的那个或者别的什么。但从技术层面上讲，我确实有一个来自片场的“世界上最棒的老板”马克杯，我猜。如果你想牵强地
which is a bummer. And I've often thought about trying to repair them. So I wouldn't put them back on. So I have a Mike bobblehead and I do have somewhere and I don't even know where there was a moment at which the everyone realized that the world's best boss mug would be a thing that was going to matter for the run of the show. And Phil ordered like 24 of them, just as in case they broke or in case we needed more of them or whatever. And I asked him if I could have one and he gave me one. So I have a world's best boss mug, not one that was ever used. It's not a famous one. It's not the one from the opening credits or anything. But I do have a world's best boss mug that is technically speaking from the set, I guess. If you want to stretch the
重新定义“来自片场”的话。你知道你还有什么吗？你还有你的装有所有笔记的文件夹。这对我来说太神奇了。我有那个。我有很多笔记本，从那些早期日子保留到现在，我至今还会翻看。对。而且我确信在某个地方还零星散落着其他几样东西。有人，我想是在大结局之后，服装部问我是否想留下任何迈克的衣服。而我相信我的回答是：请把它付之一炬。哦天哪，迈克，这太有趣了。非常感谢你。谢谢你们邀请我。见到你们俩太好了。我很高兴你们能成为这部剧的官方声音。在我看来，由你们的眼睛来带领世界见证这部剧，简直再合适不过了。哦，你这么说太客气了。
definition of from the set. And you know, what else you have is you have your binder with all your notes. That is amazing to me. I have that. I have a lot of notebooks that I still look at from those early days. Yeah. And I'm sure there's a couple other things here and there somewhere. Someone, I think after the finale, Wardrobe asked me if I wanted to keep any of the most clothes. And I believe what I said was please burn them in a fire. Oh my gosh, Mike, this was so fun. Thank you so much. Thank you for having me. It's so nice to see you too. I'm so pleased that you are the official voice of the show. It seems very fitting to me that the world is seeing the show through your eyes. Oh, that's very kind of you to say.
我们太喜欢了。这太棒了。我喜欢和迈克聊天。我可以跟他聊上一整天。我也是。他对我们说，伙计们，他说：如果你对《办公室》或其他事情有什么问题，随时告诉我。当时我就想：詹娜，我们到底能多久给他发一次短信？绝对是。绝对是。是的，迈克，准备好迎接一波电子邮件狂轰滥炸吧。你很喜欢“狂轰滥炸”（flurry）这个词。很可爱。这是一阵轰炸。我是说，与其说是詹娜在轰炸你的手机，不如说是她在对你的手机进行邮件轰炸。我要轰炸它。好吧，伙计们，迈克的新书叫《如何完美：每个道德问题的正确答案》（How to Be Perfect: The Correct Answer to Every Moral Question）。现已上市。而且迈克真的把自己从这本书中获得的
We're loving it. That was amazing. I love talking to Mike. I could talk to him forever. Me too. And he said to us, you guys, he was like, if you ever have any questions for me about anything for the office or other things, let me know. And I was like, Jenna, how often can we text him? Exactly. Exactly. Yes, Mike, get ready for an email flurry. You love the word flurry. It's cute. It's a flurry. I mean, instead of Jenna's blowing up your phone, she flurries up your phone. I'm going to flurry it. Well, you guys, Mike's book is called How to Be Perfect, the correct answer to every moral question. It is out now. And Mike really is giving away 100% of everything he's
全部收入的100%都捐给了五个不同的慈善机构。这本书太棒了。好吧，伙计们，这就是我们这周的节目。非常感谢大家收听本期“办公室女士”。下周，我们将迎来“晋升”。是的。吉姆在办公室里得到了一个小小的迷你办公室。他得到了一个玻璃盒子。他确实得到了。在开敞式办公区的中间。这既奇怪又有趣。我们会把一切都告诉你。下周见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目执行制作人为科迪·费舍。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的助理
making on his book to five different charities. And the book is awesome. Well, that's our show this week, guys. Thank you so much for listening to this episode of Office Ladies. Next week, we have the promotion. Yeah, Jim gets a little mini office in the office. He gets a glass box. He does. In the middle of the bullpen. It's strange and interesting. And we'll tell you all about it. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate
制作人是恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听无广告版本的“办公室女士”，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium上免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码OFFICE。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
制作人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 注册即可享受一个月的免费试用，使用代码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。